This is Jocko podcast number one 35 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Okay,
dear Mrs. Spearing,
there is grief in my heart and in the hearts of all my comrades for the great
sorrow that this war has brought to you and to us.
We all unite to express our heartfelt sympathy and condolences to the mother and
family of one who has fallen in a cause as imperishable as will be the names of
those who have fallen to defend it.
Should there be anything my comrades and I can do to mitigate your grief.
Okay,
and to allay your sorrow.
Some little keepsake of Walt as a marine perhaps,
but name it dear lady
and it shall traverse the ocean to you.
Yeah,
because you do not know me.
Please do not think it presumptuous for me to write.
You are Walter's mother.
I was his inseparable friend and comrade
that makes us to kindred souls in common grief for our nearest and dearest.
Then to this letter fulfills my duty that I am bound by oath and will to
perform.
Many months ago,
Walton,
I promised each other that should the god of battles called to one.
The other would console the sorrowing mother.
Yeah.
Now Walt has gone west to home and to you forever.
Okay.
But his figure,
his voice,
his wonderful personality will always be living truths to me.
I myself should the great call,
calm,
we'll go gladly
confident of a reunion and with faith in the eternal truth of that cause for
which I die
beneath the green and bellow woods forever connected to the honor of the
Marines,
lies waltz with his two comrades,
dead on the field of honor
above their graves.
The stately pines sway in their grand jury,
an imperishable monument,
but greatest of all epitaphs is that engraved within the hearts of his comrades,
a man then whom there was no PIR
in kindliness and understanding in comradeship beyond compare.
We alone know what could have been had circumstances,
so willed it,
whatever befall whatever sorrow fills us.
One thing I swear to you here,
hard by that lonely grave,
the very paper that I write upon taken in a captured German dug out.
I swear that Walt as well avenged that he has died.
Not In vain.
Okay.
For his spirit.
We just on two ultimate victory.
Okay.
You aren't proud.
I know for you are the mother of a murder,
a murder in a holy cause.
Freedom
and liberty.
Dear Lady,
the very thought that you are in grief.
Tears my heart.
Do not sorrow.
Death after all is not so terrible.
And here
why here
it is glorious.
Okay
mother
in the name of the 23rd company in the name of the Marines,
I salute you
and all my comrades salute you.
Devotedly
Saul Segal.
And that was a letter written by Saul Segal
who was in oh three 33 heavy machine gunner.
Okay.
And he was 20 years old when he wrote that letter at the graveside of his marine
corps brother.
Yeah.
To Walter spearing was his name,
who was from Philadelphia,
who'd been amongst the earliest of the Marines to ship over the war.
And who was one of the 1,811 Americans killed at the battle of Bell Eau Wood.
Yeah.
And Walter spearing died on June 26 1918 and as you said,
that letter was written on captured paper from a German dug out and you're here
that writing,
yeah,
that articulate that,
that poetic writing by a 20 year old Marine Corps machine gunner
and it's a letter that captures
so many different aspects of war
and in capturing different aspects of war.
It teaches us,
teaches us about leadership.
It teaches us about human nature,
teaches us about suffering.
It teaches us about death.
I ended,
teaches us
about life
and tonight back here again to
talk to us about all those different subject as a marine that I was honored to
serve with on the battlefield and who I am now honored to work with once again
on a different front.
His name is Dave Burke.
He's been on the podcast before already,
so if you haven't heard that one,
it was podcast number 69 and you should listen to that one first to hear about
Dave's incredible background as a Marine Corps F 18 fighter pilot,
F 16 pilot f 22 pilot f 35 pilot top gun pilot,
topcon instructor,
top guns,
senior instructor,
and of course Anglico team leader on the ground with us in the battle of Ramadi.
And if you've listened to podcasts 69 then you can hear all about that.
And tonight we'll go a little deeper on all these different subjects.
Dave,
thanks for coming back on the show.
Thanks Jack.
I'm stoked to be here man.
You just find these letters like that and it's,
it's incredible.
I know.
I was like,
Hey,
read this.
And you know your reactions like this is a 20 year old marine.
Yeah.
Is it a different time?
Is it the language is different back then.
Yeah,
and the language is different and if you just hear the words,
it sounds like a completely different world.
And then when you think about what he's saying,
I know exactly what do you can,
you can feel what he's feeling and it comes through so,
so clearly.
And
I've read letters like that.
I've heard you read letters like that.
I've seen letters like that and I've written a letter like that.
It didn't sound that eloquent.
It didn't.
Um,
but I know that and it's incredible that after all this time how powerful that
comes through,
man.
It was,
that's awesome.
As you [inaudible] this is another thing that you and I were talking about,
these lessons that exists in history,
in literature and,
and it's funny because it's,
it's things that are written by privates.
It's things that are written by corporals.
It's things that are written by majors and colonels and generals.
And it's things that are written by emperors and it's things that are written by
conscripts and everything in between.
And
every time I,
even that right there,
it's like I get another angle to appreciate and to realize.
And then you start,
you know,
you started,
I'll cover Bellwood on this podcast for sure.
But I mean,
when you read about Bellwood at all,
it was just savage battle.
Yeah.
Savage battle.
I mean there's one medal of honor for,
for a guy that his buddy didn't have his gas mask,
so he took off his own gas mask and gave it to him and then,
and then died.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's unbelievable.
And so you were telling me you kind of opened it back up the history books,
the war books.
Yeah.
I used to,
certainly as a kid and an early in my career,
I would read military history all the time.
I mean,
some of them it was an assignment,
you know,
he'd become a lieutenant in the marine corps and there is a kind of a reading
list and you want to go through and you do,
some of it are kind of,
they call it professional military education PME.
Uh,
but I used to be really interested in it and I just kind of do it on my own.
A lot of it was aviation centric,
but I got away from it.
And for the latter half of my career,
I didn't do military history at all.
Uh,
it wasn't,
um,
it just wasn't something that really captivated me.
And in the last year and a half or so,
partially not partially,
mostly because of this podcast,
I've actually gone back and read,
read some of the books and,
and you and I've talked about it a lot of different ones.
Um,
with the old breed Eugene sledge.
So that was a book I read a long time ago and it was,
it was incredible book,
very powerful.
But I went back and reread that book a little while back
and I had stopped thinking and paying attention to the meanings I was,
I was,
I was almost paying attention to the chronology in the past,
okay,
this is happening here,
this is the lesson learned and this is the movement.
And it was all kind of very sanitary and I lost what it meant to hear their
stories.
And I used to read them and I think I just tried to pay attention to what
happened and not really learn as much from him or from them.
And,
and I've read more in the last year than I had,
honestly,
docker,
py,
the previous five if not more.
Um,
and I'm reading
all the time and I'm an,
and once you start sort of digging into that world,
there's,
there's more books than I could ever read in my entire life.
They're everywhere.
Um,
and it has renewed the way I though how much I read,
but it's also changed the way I read.
It's been a really good experience for me.
I've learned a lot in the last year.
The,
uh,
and this is another thing that I talked to you about that as we were talking
about this subject the other day and I brought up this quote from Musashi.
Yeah.
And,
and the quote is,
if,
you know the way broadly you will see it and everything.
And to me that is what makes,
that is what has,
um,
I guess recalibrated reading for me is that when you start seeing all these
connections and everything,
and,
and part of it quite frankly,
comes from the fact that I wrote a book that is about this subject.
And once you go that deep in it,
it's like,
okay,
now I start seeing it everywhere.
And I mean even,
I kind of all started,
it definitely all started with about face for me with about face for me when I
was in Iraq and I knew,
I knew about face was a great book.
And this is,
this is on my second,
but on my first deployment,
my book was with the old breed as a matter of fact.
That was my book.
Yeah.
And I thought,
okay,
but it was so disconnected.
It was such a stretch.
I mean,
my first appointment to Iraq was absolutely,
absolutely nothing like with the old breed other,
the fact that we were American,
like the similarities ended there.
Right.
It was nothing like with the old breed,
nothing you know,
other than in my mind,
okay,
well these are horrible things that are happening.
You just,
it was really hard to make that connection.
I'll tell you what though,
our deployment to her Mahdi the similarities between Ramadi and and about face
were incredible.
Not just,
you know,
one of the things that hit me right out of the gate is when Hackworth gets to
Vietnam and those guys were getting killed and they're getting killed by sniper
fire,
indirect fire and booby traps,
which we now call ids for whatever reason.
And that one section in the book where they've taken hundreds,
like a hundred something casualties,
and they've,
they've contacted the enemy's zero times entity.
It's an enemy killed zero.
And I'm thinking to myself,
this is a nightmare.
This is a nightmare.
And that nightmare,
it shows itself over and over and over again.
And what's so hard is,
and I'll tell you where he hit me again,
it hit me again on,
on Lewis Polar,
when Lewis Puller is rotating between the three different sections in one of
them was called Riviera.
And he's saying every time they go into Riviera,
they take wounded or they take killed.
And on top of that,
they don't ever see the enemy.
And I'm thinking to myself,
it's maddening,
right?
It's maddening when you look back and you're detached,
which were detached now.
And I don't know if culture's different.
I don't know if our culture is different.
I don't know if we value human life more.
I don't know that.
But when you read it,
it's maddening to think about that.
And you could see that like Hackworth who he,
he didn't like that.
He didn't like that at all.
And that was all that was,
I think maybe it was you that told me when I had Jim Akiyama on and,
or a couple people told me they were like,
you sounded diddy.
Yeah.
And I said,
well,
yes,
I was giddy and,
and here I was.
But it was very interesting to go and talk to Mooky Yama because what was
interesting to me is you,
you,
there's the,
there's the public persona of some guy that was in the military,
right?
Right.
There's the public persona of some guy that was in the military,
myself included,
you,
all of us.
There's that public persona of,
Oh,
this is what this guy is perceived as.
But then there's like,
okay,
what about all the people that served with that person?
What do they really think and what was Hackworth really like?
And so going to meet moocs.
I was very curious.
Now I had read an interview with him where I knew that he had these very,
he held him in the highest esteem.
They didn't come as a surprise to me,
but still it was,
it was incredible that the perception that I had of Hackworth was accurate.
It was accurate.
And when you,
when you,
when you heard mark talk about it,
when he said,
we called the Mr Infantry,
I,
I was just thinking to myself,
is there any thing cooler in the world than to be known throughout the army as
Mr Infantry?
Yeah.
You said something that,
that,
that jumped out at me a little bit.
You were,
you were just talking about,
you know,
is,
is culture different?
Something different.
So let me just say this a little bit because you know,
I've even thought a little bit about why do I see things differently than I used
to?
What,
why have I evolved in a certain way?
So did I spend 23 years in the Marine Corps,
23 years as a US marine and a whole bunch of years just wanting to be a marine.
I was in Ramadi for seven months.
So if you just kind of do the math,
it's just not a lot of time.
Everything I think about every leadership lesson,
every when I hear you talk about a book,
when I read a book,
when I think all of those things,
the frame of reference I had,
the thing I think about is those seven months.
And had I not had those seven months of,
and
look,
Ramadi obviously was,
it was a maddening place.
It was crazy.
Um,
but if I didn't have that,
I don't think I would be able to appreciate or understand and without that frame
of reference,
without that understanding of some connection to that,
it actually makes it difficult.
And I would've never guessed it.
If I were to tell you,
hey,
I'm going to look back in my 23 year career and all those things,
I heard you listened to my bio.
It's always strange to hear someone read it out.
The,
the,
the most powerful thing in that was seven months in Ramadi,
w that's the thing that outshines all of it because of what you just described
because of that feeling.
Um,
and I don't know if it's that,
that that culture is different or society's differently.
We have different values that we value human life different differently.
But without the frame of reference,
it can be hard to capture.
But if you start to think of it in,
in a different way,
and that's sort of what that quote means.
And I know this is kind of a deep thought,
but that's,
you see things differently and you think about things that,
and you start to see things you didn't even know were there before.
And that's why when I went back and read,
look,
I've read a book and I read the exact same book again,
and to see and hear and understand things differently the second time when a
book,
that was the end for me,
for me it was with the old way.
That was the book that sort of hit me square.
I got to go to Okinawa,
I got to walk that ground that and to go back and reread that book recently and
have it seemed so different.
That has really stuck with me.
And that was sort of the reason why I got back into reading some of them the
same books and some,
some are different,
but there is something about that perspective that changes you.
And I would have never guessed that throughout my career.
I always wanted to be a pilot.
It's delivering,
really wanted to do that.
I would sort of define my experience based on those seven months and how that
influenced everything that I see now.
And the weird thing is about Rahmati is when you compare Ramadi to pell Lou,
you compare Ramadi to Okinawa,
you compare Ramadi to Normandy,
you compare Ramadi to,
you compare Ramadi to those places.
And our experience was just,
it just pales.
It just absolutely pails.
Yeah.
You and I have talked about this a lot.
Um,
you actually sent me,
I think he sent me a text or an email a couple of weeks ago.
You're like,
Hey,
do me a favor.
Um,
just verify.
I got this right.
I wanted just to make sure I got your combat experience,
um,
in,
in your first deployment.
Correct.
And it was that I was in combat in Iraq and I was thinking,
yeah,
no,
you've got it all right.
I,
I dropped a bomb
that was my car.
That was a legitimate combat experience before.
That's pre nine 11 or pre nine 11.
And we're one of the few guys with combat combatants.
Yeah.
You had dropped a bomb bomb singular and I,
the thought wasn't just how ridiculous that sounds,
but I thought,
I don't ever Charlie plummer,
bill reader to hear me say that.
I don't want them to almost embarrassed.
And,
and even like you said,
Ramadi,
w w which for me,
which was sort of like the world series and the Superbowl combined into one,
like the most powerful thing.
And with the old breed,
since we've been talking about that,
you talk about the battle of Okinawa and what they endured.
I mean,
it is so humbling and almost honestly man,
downright a little embarrassing to try to share the same experience.
We saw that with Tom five and I remember Tom five was on the podcast and he was
so grateful for,
for,
he was thanking me for what we had done and what we accomplished.
And I'm thinking this is a man that has a purple heart from World War II,
Korea and Vietnam and he's thanking me for what I did.
And um,
you know,
that's,
that's a frame of reference that I think is important and something that podcast
does is so extreme.
The wells,
it gives those guys a chance to share that story at that.
Otherwise they wouldn't get a chance to.
Is there a way to get,
I'm trying to figure out what I was missing,
right.
I was trying to fit,
I'm trying to figure out what,
how can you get somebody that's a 18 year old corporal to read a book with the
perspective,
the,
with the right perspective.
Is that possible
at 18 year old day,
Burke,
it wasn't possible.
I can tell you that for sure.
It wasn't.
Um,
and I,
I don't know if that,
if that's the case,
but I do know that if you get an 18 year old de Burgh agent or anybody to to
start to read it,
start to think about it,
that actually builds over time.
And that creates some sort of foundation that I think with time of perspective,
you can actually reach those,
reach that.
But there's no way at that age,
no matter what you said,
no matter how articulate you are,
no matter how powerful the story was,
I don't think you're reaching me.
And I don't mean that to be discouraging,
but I think that's a hard lesson.
I think you know,
for certainly what I was going through at that time of my life,
it's just not going to happen.
It's going to,
yeah,
it's when it's too,
cause what you're focused on when your ATM and you read with the old breed,
you're like,
like I remember my earliest memories of with the old breed are these guys were
ripping people's gold teeth with pliers.
You're thinking,
whoa,
that's crazy.
Like,
that's the big,
that's,
that's probably the big takeaway from my first read when I was whatever years
old yep.
Of with the old breed.
It's you,
you see it for the things that seem not real and you're like,
man,
that is incredible in that as awesome.
And um,
I also think that goes to the,
you talked about this a lot,
that,
that sort of,
that feeling of invincibility too when you're young and they'd like immune to
not just the physical risks,
not just the potential of getting hurt or getting injured or getting shot or
some of those worse things,
but the mental and emotional risks that go along with experiencing that.
Um,
that's a really hard lesson.
Now the other side of that is,
you know,
when I deployed to Ramadi,
almost everybody on my team was a first appointment brand new,
young US marine.
Um,
you met Marcus Perez,
he came to,
uh,
the muster,
you know,
he was a young kid.
Uh,
and you walk in there sort of with this kind of,
this bulletproof approach.
And
it's not how it is when you leave.
It's not the same.
And in some ways,
like you said,
the scale is,
is different than a Manoppello Lou or Guadalcanal or any of those things,
you know,
that that we just talked about.
But when it's happening to you,
it's,
it could be a single round,
a single mortar,
a single shot,
a single wound.
If it's happening to you,
it sort of feels like it's happening to the whole world.
It's really impactful.
And that's probably why,
if I look back on my career,
the thing that's the most powerful experience that I had,
that sort of outshines everything,
bye bye so much is,
is that time in Ramadi because I was exposed to things that I never saw as a
pilot and never would have seen had I not been on that deployment.
You know what I was,
I was thinking.
So one of the things,
and I remember probably,
I don't know if it was 10 or 15 podcasts deep into into this podcast,
I remember saying during one of the podcasts,
and,
and I've said it a few times along the way,
I remember saying that these people that I'm talking about in these books,
they're not characters.
These are people.
And I think at some point for me that transition in my brain happened where I
was saying to myself,
these are,
these are people.
And I think I got a little bit of it in my platoon commander tour because you
know,
there was a,
it was a,
it was a good solid deployment.
Was there risk?
Sure there was rescue.
It wasn't super high risk.
I had,
I had a great crew of guys,
but you know,
there was,
there was stress and there was personalities.
And you start to see that when you read about a guy and you think,
I kind of know that guy,
just,
I just know him a little bit.
And,
and you start to realize that those people in these books,
they're real people.
And I think that for me was a huge leap between connecting me to the text that I
was reading.
And I'll tell you another thing and straight up voice w w w when I started
thinking about reading these things,
when I started reading these aloud,
when I started reading them and hearing them in my own headset,
like on the podcast,
that was an impact.
And,
and now it's happened.
It happened with bill reader happened with Jody Mitic had happened when these
guys come on here and they hear me read what they wrote and it hits them.
And so that's another part of it too.
There is an element when you read that's missing.
There is an element of voice that is just more powerful.
It's just more powerful.
And I remember when I read the forgotten Highlander,
when I read that book,
I read it on the plane coming back,
calling a guy over in Scotland,
a buddy of mine who I'd done some work with.
He gave me this book and I was on podcast 11 and he goes,
hey,
you gotta check out this book.
I won't try and do a Scottish accent.
Plus he's a Mumbler Hema.
Like there you go to check up to the book.
And so he gives me this book and I'm sort of thinking,
okay,
you know,
I just,
I wasn't sure,
but I had made enough of a enough of a leap in my brain that when I started
reading that book,
I said to myself,
wow,
this is going to be,
this is going to be a really powerful podcast.
So I read the book.
So then when we come,
this is podcast number 12 when we can't,
when I came in to record it,
I thought,
yeah,
this is going to be really heavy.
But when I read it,
it was like I was getting hit in the head with,
with a sledge hammer.
And that's the first podcast that when I got to the end of the book,
I actually didn't know what to say because what do you say?
What do you say about a guy that,
what do you say about a guy that,
that,
that put maggots on his flesh to eat away the dead flesh.
What do you say about that?
And so that's the first podcast where I said when I got done with it,
the next time I did a podcast that was heavy like that,
I knew that I had to get myself some weird to go.
I had to give myself some fought about how am I going to make this?
How does this become something?
How do I,
how do I get out of this hole?
Cause that's what,
that's what you're doing.
And so there's a level of that as well.
When you hear,
like when you hear a hardcore history podcast,
you'd get great storytelling,
but he's reading quotes from people.
But it's so much more powerful when you hear it audibly.
And we,
you know,
people say that about extreme ownership to people say,
Oh yeah,
I love that book and this,
and we'll say,
you got to get the audio audio cause it's Lafe and I reading it and you can
hear,
I mean how much is communicated in the tone of voice.
There's a lot
when you said earlier about the,
the audible piece of that
when you finish my first podcast.
So when I was on,
it was,
we were talking about this almost a year and a half ago now,
you know,
April I think of last year,
I guess
you finished with a letter that cat wrote to Chris.
Now I didn't know we hadn't discussed that and I didn't know how it was going to
finish and uh,
you know,
we spent all that time,
talking about me and my experiences and things like that.
I knew that letter.
Well I have a copy of that
letter and I've read that letter several times.
I had never read that letter out loud to myself.
I never read a tender.
But as I've shared it with Whitney and I've shared that letter.
Okay.
Hearing you say a letter that I knew almost line by line.
I know that letter really well made that letter like I'd never heard it before
and I remember it.
Look,
it's hard to hear it because it's Chris and it's hard for me because that's a
really impactful thing,
very emotional thing,
and that is a,
that's a crusher for me,
man.
I know you understand that,
but I had never heard it out loud.
And in,
there's a book I'm reading now that I have read the preface of the book,
which is only about three pages kind of just explained.
I've read it out loud to myself like five times,
and it,
it's,
it's something that I overlooked the impact of hearing it as opposed to reading.
And I read the book and really cool buck.
I think I sent you,
this book's awesome.
You should check it out.
I read the,
the,
the preface out loud to myself and having him read it three or four times
already hearing it,
it was like reading it for the first time.
The,
the voice that you give that makes,
it makes the words become real.
Like,
uh,
like that person who wrote the book is saying out loud.
And that difference there,
it's not subtle.
It's huge.
It's a huge,
huge thing that that is one of the great things about when people do it.
When they do it on podcasts and you're putting somebody else's voice into
action,
most of the time we're reading books by people that are long gone.
Uh,
and you're telling stories that nobody would ever hear.
And even if you read them,
it misses something.
And,
and I think the power of that is huge.
And it brought me right back to our last podcast,
which was you sitting right where you are reading cats letter to Chris.
And as it,
like I said,
like I had never heard it before.
It was,
it's a totally different level.
You know what a podcast
was.
Another podcast that,
that sort of caught me was,
uh,
one soldiers war by,
um,
our Katie and that part in the end of that podcast where it's,
again,
that was podcast number 18.
And he's,
he's,
he's quoting these wounded soldiers that were sitting begging for money
basically.
And
he's talking about how this guy is saying,
you know,
if I would kill all these,
he's talking about this,
this soldiers talking about everyone on the streets in Moscow.
He says,
I would kill every one of these people to bring back my brothers.
You're reading this going,
oh good God.
That is a powerful,
powerful book.
Did you see him in the news recently?
No.
He faked his own death.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Yes.
All of these people we talked about it.
He did.
They hit me up on social media and I was all,
man,
what a travesty.
And yeah,
it was totally bummed out and then sure enough he had faked his own death.
He even food his wife and tell his wife that's,
that takes a lot of courage.
He's a courageous guy already.
But yeah,
to fake your death and not give your wife a heads up about it.
That's,
that's hardcore.
That that's problematic.
Yeah.
And,
and that,
that feeling too,
it's one thing to sort of have that feeling,
but to be willing to express that feeling of that,
I would do that to all of these people.
That is,
that's it.
That's saying a lot,
man.
I mean,
that is deep to to,
I've had some pretty hardcore thoughts certainly in my time.
Like,
no,
I'm fine.
I can share that one.
Uh,
but to put it out there,
you know what I mean?
That's,
that gets to the core of,
of just how,
how much people feel from those experiences,
just how powerful those feelings are.
And those guys had no mercy.
Those,
those Russian soldiers,
they had no mercy.
It was that,
that part where he's talking about the sergeants beat the corporals,
the captains beat the sergeants,
the majors beat the captain's.
Yeah.
It's just a nightmare.
It's just a complete nightmare.
It makes you wonder how any of that is,
is makes any remotely functional.
Like how does that system function at all under that setting,
under that environment.
How could anybody at the bottom of that hierarchy be willing to go do any of the
things they went and did you know you,
you're talking about,
you know the,
this thing from,
from bell eau wood there,
they literally know most of you are going to die.
We're going to charge across open fields into machine guns.
We use that example.
That echelon front is something that you would never do.
And that's what they were doing.
I mean,
borderline,
just human waves.
If we do it enough,
we're going to get 50,
75 yards of terrain out of it.
We're going to move the line forward a hundred yards and we're going to send a
wave after wave after wave two.
And guys who lived right like this is Bert borderline a death sentence.
Um,
what,
what people are capable of doing and under those environments is,
is unreal.
Sometimes World War One,
it just is.
It's just,
you know,
it's,
you know what's funny is I say that about everyone,
every war.
So the board were like unbelievable.
And then you,
you talked about Napoleon and like nothing like that.
And then I read the book on the coldest a war or a colder than hell.
I'm like,
no,
nothing like that.
Like there is,
there is something that has happened in every one of the stories that you've
talked about or I think how is that possible?
And they all have their own unique thing about them that just seems unreal.
I'm going to throw in an orange vest and mark by position in 30 below so you can
see me so you know where I am because I'm the leader because I'm the leader and
you get
Lee.
Yeah.
Unreal.
That being said,
World War One,
no,
I don't.
I don't know that,
that,
I don't know that that is out there.
The the complete lack of control that you had as a individual soldier.
Yeah.
As a,
even as a platoon commander,
as a company commander,
you had no control over your fate.
That's,
that's what scares me so much about world war one.
It wasn't like,
Hey Jocko,
here's,
here's the situation,
here's what we're trying to accomplish.
Why don't you go figure out the best way to do it?
And I go,
okay,
you know what,
cool,
I can do this.
We can,
we can come up with some cool tactics.
We can make some stuff happen.
It was,
hey,
tomorrow morning at zero 614,000 of us are going to go at zero 600 and then
guess what's going to happen to zero six 15 another 14,000 yeah,
and guess what's going to happen to zero six 30 another 14,000 and guess what?
Of vast majority.
Then we're going to be wounded or killed and that's that.
So that that to me and,
and I'll tell you what
they call that,
the war to end all wars.
I think if there would have been internet
photographers,
Instagram,
Twitter,
youtube,
that might have been the last war,
right?
That might've been the last war.
If you were a,
and it's not that if you saw that as a leader because I'm just,
when I think about it,
I think about it like you're a general and you're in charge and you organize
this big operation and then you,
you give the execute order and then 22,000 men are killed in the first 24 hours.
Who does that?
Who does that now?
And this is,
this is a dichotomy because are there situations where people have done
operations and are there situations that warm that it's like,
hey,
guess what,
we are going to do this mission and we don't have a real good chance of coming
back.
And that's the way it is.
And it's a strategic piece of the mission and it,
does that happen?
Could that happen?
Absolutely.
And do people in the military sign up for that?
Would I sign up for that?
If that was what was required?
Well yeah,
that's what we signed up for.
But it has a leader like that to be sitting there looking at 25,000 men and you
gained,
you know,
75 yards of mud and you know what?
You Go,
okay,
that was bad.
We're not going to do that again.
No,
no,
no.
You know what you say,
you know what,
we'll do it harder.
Right.
We'll do it harder,
which is,
which is what makes me,
it makes that war to me just absolutely sickening.
It's sickening.
It is.
It absolutely is.
And the calculus that goes into that is something
is completely disconnected from the value of human life.
Completely disconnected of what that impact is.
And then you,
you read this letter,
okay.
And that's 14,000 moms
on that one wave,
that one time.
That's 14,000 of these letters and uh,
the disconnect of,
of human life.
Um,
yeah.
It's,
it's an,
it's actually hard,
kind of hard to fathom.
You you talked about,
you know,
yeah.
The high risk operation,
you know,
we're going to go in,
uh,
into the worst possible situations cause yeah.
And you know what?
We all kind of secretly would say,
Hey,
I'm the volunteer for that.
You know,
the high risk,
but as as it,
that's just how we do operations all the time.
That's just what we do.
Yeah,
no,
that's a,
that's actually a nightmare.
Yeah.
In the other thing with World War One,
right?
Like World War II,
you're looking at Nazis.
Yeah.
And you're looking at the imperial Japanese army and you're thinking,
we've got real bad guys here.
We got legit bad guys.
That's,
that's a factor too,
right?
It Germany,
World War One.
It's like,
well yeah,
we want it a little extra land.
Who's that land for?
You know what I talk about with you?
Don't worry.
We will work with companies.
And I say,
so,
okay.
CEO says,
I,
you know,
my frontline troops aren't doing what they're supposed to do and it's affecting
our bottom line.
And you know,
ask them,
oh,
well you gotta explain to them why it's important.
Right.
And sort of then see yoga goes down and says,
hey,
you guys need to do a better job on the front lines so that the company can be
more profitable.
And the frontline people are like,
we don't care if it call you.
That doesn't mean that doesn't matter to me.
Yeah.
I'm making 17 bucks,
17 bucks an hour,
and I got a wife and I've got a kid and I got a basketball game tonight and
we've got a mortgage and I got a house payment.
The company and being profitable,
it makes no difference to me whatsoever.
Yeah.
So imagine now your World War One and you're going to get an extra 14 miles of
land.
That's the goal to get 14 miles of land in some country and it's not for you.
It's for like the government.
Yeah.
It's,
yeah.
It's absolutely,
it's atrocious.
Yeah.
And,
and when you're sending US marines across the Atlantic Ocean to get engaged in
that war is like to keep Germany from encroaching a little bit too far west.
You know Brian France.
Yeah,
maybe.
Yeah.
The,
the wide isn't,
that doesn't,
that doesn't resonate.
They have.
I,
have I ever talked about it?
Do,
I don't know if I've talked about,
have I ever talked about the white flower thing?
They didn't in Britain,
the white flour.
So if you were like a able bodied young man,
if you were a military age male,
yeah.
And,
and you weren't wearing a uniform and you weren't like fighting,
women would come up and give you a white flower.
It was the mark of shame and the government started that campaign.
Yeah.
The government started that campaign of,
Hey,
you see,
you see someone that's not in uniform military age,
male able bodied fighting man.
You go up and give him a white flower.
He's a coward.
Um,
I'm prepping a book right now for the podcast and actually a couple of books,
but it's a nightmare because what they're doing is they're,
they're executing British soldiers that have that,
that,
that dessert or run away or have shell shock.
Yeah.
They're just dysfunctional.
They can't do it anymore.
And it's,
it's awful.
Some of the stories.
These guys are soldiers that had been on the line for a year and they break the
break,
which everyone,
um,
Dick winters talks about.
People braved the bravest guys he had.
They might break and you've got to get them off the wide Hackworth.
Same thing.
You've got brave guys sometimes you've got to get him off the line.
World War One,
we got a British soldier.
He's been fighting for a year in the trenches.
He's been getting mortared.
He's been getting bombed that he'd says,
I can't do this anymore.
Okay,
we're going to shoot you at dawn.
And they did it.
Yeah.
That's another thing.
It's completely insane.
Yeah.
We use the analogy a lot.
We talked about this additional in front.
You're like,
Hey,
it's your folks when you're pushing your folks too hard.
It's like,
it's like driving a car in the red.
You were running this car in the red.
You're running them hard and if you keep them in the red too long,
that car's going to break that and then she's going to break.
Now you can,
you can push to the red a little bit.
You can kind of throttle up and,
and do that.
And then you got to bring them back.
And that's sort of one of the leader's job is that it sort of pay attention to
that.
And this is the idea of like,
I'm going to run my car in the red until my car explodes and then I'm going to
be mad at the car.
I'm gonna blame the car.
Uh,
and the,
the disconnect of the,
and we'd,
like you said that the disconnect of the impact of the human being that,
that,
that that's what leaders are supposed to do.
That's their job is to,
and Dick winters had that he talked about the idea of like,
hey,
when,
when somebody puts their head in their hands that's,
they live physical,
they're literally showing you,
hey man,
um,
I'm breaking right now.
And the willingness to just say,
go do it again and then get to the point of like,
I can't,
and then go,
we're done with you.
We don't have any more use for you anymore.
Yeah.
Um,
that's hard to comprehend.
It's hard to comprehend.
But like I said,
I'm prepping these books.
It's awful to read them.
Some of them are of the quotes from the soldiers that were chosen to be the
executioners,
right?
I mean,
well,
what's that?
What's that?
I remember I started one podcast off of that was like the soldiers were picked
to go this,
this kid had been in the army for a couple weeks and he had to go shoot a
deserter.
That was his one of his first assignments.
What the hell?
Yeah.
So there's some kind of a sum or some kind of Af I,
you know,
do we value human life more now?
That's the question.
I think the answer,
if you compare today compared to World War One,
the answer is 100% yes.
Without a doubt.
100% yes we do.
We do in the military would do and we do everywhere.
I think we absolutely do.
You got a nice long history of podcasts that are just sort of soul crushing.
You know,
we've hit some real home runs there with them to some podcasts.
You're like,
wow,
that is,
that is hard.
But you know what,
the reason that we hold human life in greater value now is because of that is
because of those stories is because this letter,
I mean there's that,
that small piece of having to understand that we are here because of where we
came from.
We are here because of what we did and what we endured.
And that's not to say we won't go back to do that again.
That doesn't mean that we can't end up back in that place.
But those,
those stories that,
that legacy of that just
crazy impossible to understand how you can do that to that many people and just
say,
that's just how we do business.
That's just what we do.
Um,
we have come a long way and I think we've moved in the right direction.
Now.
There is a piece that
when people go to war,
people die.
Oh yeah.
You know,
that's,
and we,
we can't get to a place or to a point or to a belief in our society where that
is not acceptable.
That it's,
that is not something we're willing to have happened or an order for us to be
successful.
That that is not okay to get to point that any loss of life or any injury or any
sacrifice is not okay.
We can't get to that point.
So overshooting that,
uh,
is not good either.
Um,
I wouldn't use world war one has a benchmark,
you know,
that's just,
it's not even close.
But the reality is,
is that that's not just how war is,
but that's actually necessary.
And that's,
uh,
as a leader,
that's a huge burden.
That's a huge burden.
And the burden is to balance the responsibility that you have to do everything
to ensure that doesn't happen to your people knowing full well knowing full well
that it will,
and I'll be really,
dude,
I'll be really honest with you.
I did not,
when I went to Iraq,
I did not really grasp that it might happen to my guys.
I just didn't.
And,
um,
I just
didn't give it enough thought that the risk was actually gonna end up with me
and my guys and that Chris was going to get killed.
And I looked back on that as a leader and I,
I should have thought about that more.
I should have prepared for that more and I should have known what that meant
more than I did.
And the reality is is that anybody in this business that goes to combat in any
shape or form has to be prepared for that and recognize it.
That is what happens in combat and that your job as a leader is to do everything
you can to prevent it knowing full well that that is going to happen.
That's what happens.
How long did it take you once you were on the ground in Ramadi?
Not long so,
so the,
the sledgehammer for me,
sir,
I mean I will never forget the day.
I'll never forget June 20th ever.
The sledgehammer for me was the first day I got there.
The guy that I was replacing got in a Humvee,
hit an ID.
Now he,
he,
he was wounded but he broke both of his legs in a Humvee that I was supposed to
take from him.
We were supposed to do.
The turnover of that Humvee ended up,
obviously not getting that vehicle because it got blown up,
but it was a major in the marine corps and it was like majors in a major aviator
in the Marine Corp blown up by an IED.
So I got up to speed very quickly and that place had an ability to get you to be
aware of the reality of it very fast.
So I think I got there very fast.
Day One,
something happened,
but the anticipation about getting there,
that was kind of a sledgehammer for me.
What about reading reports when you were going in?
So
I,
we talked about this last time.
My best friend was in Ramadi noodle.
Yeah,
Neil Neil was in Ramadi in third battalion,
second marines s so make no mistake Jocko.
I objectively understood what was going on.
I mean,
I was aware,
I knew I was getting myself into when I asked to go on that fact tour to Ramadi.
But the disconnect was what it meant.
It's sorta like the same disconnect that we were talking about when you read
these books.
Like you're reading reports but you're,
you're not there mentally.
Well look,
combat for me was dropping a bomb in Iraq and Afghanistan was certainly more
aggressive experience for me even though it was a lot more regular pace.
Um,
there was certainly some risk involved.
but you've talked about the first combat experience on this podcast a lot.
We've talked about just the first combat experience as well.
I did not really get it until I saw it.
And actually in some ways you could say I didn't get it until I heard it.
You know,
the sounds of combat,
what it really sounds like to have a bullet go past your head so close to you
can actually sort of gauge how close it was to your head and whether it was
closer to the guy next to you three feet away or closer to you.
Who was the sniper actually looking.
I've had those thoughts.
I know you have to.
So the sights,
the sounds of that.
Um,
it's just,
it's hard to replicate and I've actually been mds.
You've talked about the training that you did for your guys at task unit bruiser
and some of the things you did.
I didn't do a lot of those things.
You know,
and I,
and I showed up and like this is no criticism,
I'm not throwing the hidden anybody.
This is just the way it was.
I got to that,
that,
that the unit that I deployed with a,
I showed up in October,
I did some training.
Uh,
I kinda really joined the unit in earnest in like January and I was in Ramadi in
February.
We kind of,
you sort of laugh to me last time I shot my rifle in training once I s I BZ owed
Aye.
Oriented my,
my sights on my rifle when I got to Ramadi,
you know,
and that,
that training range they had just on the outside and made sure my sites,
we're in good shape before I went out on my first patrol the next day.
So in a lot of ways I was just Kinda in over my head with what that was.
And then on that deployment,
it just,
yeah,
it's crazy.
And it happens.
So there was,
you know,
that's the sort of,
uh,
the trial by fire story.
I mean,
that's what it was for me.
But I will say this,
um,
I got up to speed quickly in the re the recognition of the reality and look,
people were,
we're getting wounded,
people are getting killed pretty regularly that you can see.
I'm like,
man,
that's,
that's close to,
that's real.
That's on the street I've been on.
That's an a patrol I've done.
That's an,
an opiate I've manned.
So I,
I got to that point very quickly.
And the lessons that I had grown up with as a leader,
the way that I,
I was as a leader,
I was able to leverage that.
They,
they still worked leadership and combat.
It's,
it's certainly more dynamic.
It'll certainly strike more fear in you,
but the principles don't change.
And I was old enough and mature enough and I had enough under my belt to say,
okay,
I need to control this.
I need to control how I react in this setting and I need to do what I do and I
need to do the things that I know what I need to do.
Uh,
and I was lucky enough to be able to do that and keep my,
you know,
my wherewithal and not get overwhelmed by it.
And I saw guys get overwhelmed by it here and there and it was a place that that
could do that to you,
but I was able to fall back on
leadership principles,
how you lead a marine,
where you did you think mentally,
right?
The mental game of being able to detach and be able to take a step back.
And as a fighter pilot,
did you just say,
oh,
this is what it's like as a fighter pilot.
This is what it's like.
Oh,
I remembered.
It's like landing on an aircraft carrier.
I'm going to be stressed out when it,
oh,
I need to overcome that.
Did you just apply the same mechanisms to,
all right,
now I'm going to be stepping foot on the battlefield and this is how I need to
apply this same mentality,
the same mechanisms.
I had enough experience of being and controlling the fear that comes along with
things that are scary,
that it looked different.
It smells different,
it sounded different,
but the feeling was exactly the same.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
So that's what I was like.
Like I said,
that's why it's a softball,
cause I'm,
I'm imagining that,
you know,
even even for us,
okay,
so let's say free fall,
like you're going to free fall.
Well,
you're jumping out of an airplane.
And I was,
I thought it would be more scared the first time I jumped out of an airplane,
but I was actually pretty pumped.
So that's not a great example.
But there's times in the seal teams where you do something in training where
you're like,
okay,
this is a little bit sketch,
right?
This is a little bit sketch and you know,
what do you do?
You do the same thing,
you know,
okay,
this is what I'm gonna do.
I've practiced it,
I've rehearsed it.
I'm going to,
I'm going to execute this thing and we're going to make it happen.
And you learn how to do that.
So when you get in combat,
you have a protocol to follow to take that street.
If you're good now,
you know,
we see keep people that they,
they,
they have the protocol and they aren't able to apply it to the situation.
Yeah.
I,
I never really freaked out when I was there.
The reality was,
oh,
this is a lot closer to me than I thought it was going to be.
The reality was hitting me harder than I expected in my preparation wasn't where
it needed to be to be ready for it.
But when I got there,
I knew that feeling and I felt that several times in my career.
And their response to it is,
is it's all the same.
And one of the best things about responding to those situations is that as a
leader,
you're really busy.
There's a lot to do.
You,
you've got a lot going on.
A lot of decision you have to make a lot of things you have to be aware of and
that's actually one of the best remedies for all that and you know,
it's probably really tough for someone who really junior in the organization
that may feel like he doesn't know what's going on,
doesn't have a real sense of those things.
I was never really bored,
you know what I mean?
Of Time.
They have a lot of time now I,
I,
I know the feeling I've had it.
I felt that feeling and I was like,
man,
this is a lot different.
I'm in a Humvee,
I can't see things I'm used to being able to see my situational awareness is
different.
How I gathered information,
all that is different because the environment's different,
the feeling of the same and the responses to the same.
And like I said,
I had the luxury,
if you want to call it that.
I was always busy.
I was at stuff going on.
I had always things to do.
I never,
I didn't just sit there and think,
wow,
this is terrifying and scary and I don't know what to do.
It's
in the aftermath that look back.
Oh man,
that was,
that was crazy.
You know,
I remember I have this very vivid memory of,
of doing,
we call them,
um,
presence patrols.
So we take a couple of Humvees and cruise around and in this case it was a,
the town,
it was called [inaudible].
It was a little town in,
in Ramadi there on the south side and just a nasty place.
Just not a good place and a presence,
patrols,
religious,
you're just waiting to get shot at.
And we would weave in and out of of the the streets and you know,
the buildings are two or three stories high and we pulled up to an intersection.
Were,
were the second vehicle in this two vehicle patrol and the vehicle turns into as
soon as the vehicle in from it yet two vehicles.
Yeah.
Get some,
we're number two.
The first vehicle makes a right hand turn.
As soon as he turns.
Right.
Guy With an RPG,
I can see him up.
You know,
right at my 12 o'clock position and it goes over the hood of our vehicle,
hits the wall.
It doesn't detonate,
but I think I might've mentioned this before and I'm just yelling,
go,
go.
Uh,
and those are the stories that in the APP,
when you look back in the afternoon,
I'm like,
man,
that was crazy.
But at the time,
you don't really spend a lot of time though.
You're saying you're going to go to the right,
hey,
and you're on the radio here.
Where's the other vehicle?
Hey,
this is what,
just how you're,
you're talking,
you're communicating,
you're doing all the things you're supposed to do.
So you can look back on those things.
And a lot of times I'll look back and I'm like,
man,
that was out of control.
That was nuts.
Or,
but during those times,
even some of those,
those terrifying experiences,
I was just too busy to really worry about it.
And I was making decisions.
And I think as a leader,
that's,
that's actually good because I don't want to sit there and think about all these
things that are scaring me.
I want to just respond to it and just make a decision and do something.
Um,
and I actually had a lot of time in my career where I was,
I got very comfortable making decisions in difficult environments very quickly.
That's aviation in a nutshell.
Um,
and so I think I was able to adapt to that very quick and it's part of the
reason why I was able to get through that,
that deployment the way that I did.
You know,
I had some decompression,
we talked about that after,
after the fact,
but not a lot while I was there.
Did you ever punch out of your aircraft,
your rejects?
No.
Is that just a lot?
Yeah.
I mean some of it's beyond your control and it's pretty rare.
It doesn't happen all that often,
but not me.
Thank God.
Check.
You know,
one of the things you were talking when you were talking about,
you know,
will you basically went on a whole comment there about,
you got to,
you're in a situation,
going back to the original subject here as a leader,
you're in this situation where you're going to take these guys that you care
about and you're going to do everything to protect and your,
regardless of how much you want to protect them there,
you're going to put them in situations where they can get killed and that that
the new book coming out.
The first chapter is called the ultimate dichotomy.
It's what it's called.
It's the ultimate dichotomy and there's a reason because that is the ultimate
dichotomy.
There's know that for a leader as far as I'm concerned,
if that is the absolute hardest thing that you have to deal with as a leader,
the fact that you care about these guys,
it's your all,
you've been taught,
all you believe,
all you've think all your,
your,
your morals and your values are all of these for these guys that are doing
anything for you and you'll do anything for them and you know their families and
you know they're kids and it's like,
yeah,
guess what,
take all that and now you're going to send them on missions where there is no
doubt that they can get wounded or they can get killed.
You met Marcos at,
uh,
at the muster.
We talked about him earlier and
this is a kid that would have done
anything for me to this day.
He would do anything for me.
This is a kid that loves me.
I love this kid too.
And that's that feeling that is very hard to explain if you haven't gone through
it.
And it's very hard to describe how powerful that is at every single day.
I threw Marcos and the Turd on my Humvee stuck his head up.
You know,
it was an armored Humvee was great,
but at the end of the day,
you know what the target it has to do.
He's got to get his head up out of the Turret and man that to 40 golf or 50 cow
or whatever we had on that on any given day and stick his head out of that
Humvee every single day.
And I thought about that all the time,
all the time.
And it is exactly what you just described.
This is someone that would have done anything for me.
This is someone that I loved and would have done anything for.
And every day it was get in the turret and let's go.
That's what you do.
And you do everything you can to prepare them and everything you can to make
sure it doesn't happen.
And the last thing you tell them is,
hey,
get up there and we gotta go.
We gotta go do this.
No,
just can you even fathom,
can you even fathom that that happens?
And you do it from Monson,
you do it for months and you'd do it for a year.
And finally he says,
you know what,
I can't do this anymore.
And then you said,
you know what?
Okay,
we're pressing charges against you.
You're going to court marshal,
we find you guilty.
Okay,
that's insane.
And to take it a step further,
organize,
get somebody else in my unit to pull the trigger.
We're going to get another guy from this unit,
from this battalion,
this fund,
this team to follow through with that,
that order.
It's,
it's not actually,
no,
I can't comprehend that.
I can't understand that.
Um,
I can't,
I can't either.
I mean,
um,
like I said,
I'm doing a podcast about it in the near future.
Yeah.
But for the love of God,
that's a trajectory.
It's,
it's,
thank God,
uh,
being in this time period.
Yeah.
And we could talk about this stuff for days.
You've talked about it or would you just the last podcast with the imperial
Japanese doing those experiments.
We talked about the dehumanization and look,
obviously it's,
it's grotesque,
but the dehumanization of your enemy.
I,
I understand how that happens.
I can,
I can understand that we don't get there.
Yeah,
I can.
I can see how people can get there.
Yeah,
I can see that.
And I know that,
that I know the seeds of how that grows and I know that feeling I've had,
that feeling grows over time of,
of that disdain and that dehumanization that I said I would never have happened
to me.
And I fell.
And I know that feeling.
So I,
my point is that if you've ever heard me say with our enemy,
we didn't really have to dehumanize them because they dehumanised themselves as
we saw what they did.
I saw the acted and what they did to the civilian.
Totally.
It's absolutely you dehumanized yourselves and again,
you're going to suffer the consequences of that yet.
And so that's a bridge in my mind.
I can cross,
I understand that.
I don't understand how you can get to a point where the value of the human life
of your own men is that you just discard them at the end.
Like,
Oh,
you're done.
Got It.
Lined them up.
And that to me is kind of horrifying because I had a small unit,
I'm gonna have a big unit and I certainly knew my guys pretty well.
And maybe when you have,
you know,
a huge unit of a bunch of unnamed people you don't build strong relationships
with,
but at the end of the day that are wearing your uniform,
at the end of the day there they look,
sound talk and are just like you.
A lot of them come from the same place as you.
Um,
and that's really difficult to accept.
The human beings are capable of doing that.
Like I said,
when,
when it's your enemy or,
or it's when it's someone that's different than you,
you at least can comprehend that.
And you've see,
we've seen that in history,
but you're your own guys.
Um,
that's,
that's a different level.
It's a different time period.
Yep.
So going back to,
or not going back to you,
but going forward,
right?
You got out of the Marine Corps,
I mean obviously we covered a little bit of this on the last podcast we covered
about,
you know,
what we did,
we kind of read the text last time you were on the podcast of kind of how the
transition,
you know,
you got out,
you came to an event with Leif and I and we hung out and you were sinking
yourself.
You have this looks like,
uh,
what I want to do.
Yeah.
But there's been more to it than that
that you've kind of briefed me on a little bit
how much time we got.
Yeah,
there is,
there's a lot more to it.
Um,
the work that we do is awesome and I wrote you a letter a few,
several months ago now,
but I wrote you a letter kind of in some ways,
you know,
somebody was like,
Hey,
thank you for bringing me part of this team.
And,
and there was,
you know,
I wanted to express some gratitude and I did that to everybody to have been
brought into something that is really incredible.
And,
and,
and I wanted that to be clear,
but I also wanted to kind of explain what I was going through,
um,
is as part of the transition and
what has hit me the hardest is not the things that I expect it to happen that
have happened and look,
some really good things have happened.
This is an awesome company.
We do great things and I get there,
make an impact and I love being a part of this and I saw it.
So I sort of expected to be able to do that and be a part of that and see the
impact of that.
Um,
but I didn't give much thought at the time to how I was going to impact me and
what the impact of being a part of this would for,
for my growth.
And for myself.
I think we just talked about this earlier today when
I get introduced to these events all the time and they read my bio sometimes and
I hear the words of what we're doing and everything and what I've done.
And,
and I was at a point that I can look back and very easily think that I could
have coasted.
I could have said,
hey,
I,
I did some good work in the Marine Corps.
I got a really cool resume and I've kind of got it figured out.
I don't have that much more to learn it.
I'm going to kind of,
I'm going to glide,
you just go straight level for a while.
And the biggest part of this transition for me is the recognition
that what I have done to this point,
what I accomplished as a marine and,
and the things that I did as a pilot,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Because if I cash in now and I check in the box and I'm done,
and I,
and I coast from now all define my life by having coasted for the rest of my
life.
And I wasn't really prepared for having to recognize of how much more there is
for me to learn and how much more there is for me to do.
Um,
and that has been by far the best and the most humbling part about this.
And you got,
you know,
me at this point,
you know me well enough that I'm not afraid to admit,
you know,
things that are kind of hard to admit.
I'm not afraid to kind of humble myself.
I'm not afraid to say,
wow,
I got that wrong.
I didn't see that coming.
Um,
this transition has been way,
way more than I thought it was going to be.
Uh,
and in some ways it's actually put me on my yields a little bit.
It's been a reminder that
man,
I'm not even close to have to doing the things that I want to do before I'm
done.
I'm not even close.
And it's,
that's a hard feeling sometimes.
It's actually,
I struggle with that a little bit,
um,
because a lot of the times people around me to tell it,
tell me I've done great things and I hear that a lot and it's great to hear,
but
I'm not even close man.
And,
and,
and that is something I struggle with every day and I work at every day and I
have a lot,
a lot,
a lot to do.
I don't think that you,
you didn't get to where you were without feeling that,
right?
Yeah.
You don't get to,
you don't get to be,
you know,
the,
all the things that you did in your big bio without saying,
without,
without having the back of your mind.
Like,
I needed to do more than I need to do better.
Right?
Yeah,
that's true.
That is true.
But the magnitude of,
of it,
it gets bigger over time.
It doesn't smaller.
The magnitude continues to grow.
I know what this is.
This is like when you started Jujitsu and you're like,
well,
you know what?
He'd give me a few weeks to figure this out.
Right.
And be like,
two or three months I'll probably be tapping this guy out.
Yeah.
And then no.
Oh,
two weeks into it,
you're going,
oh my God.
There's a whole nother thing here.
Yeah.
That might be one of the best metaphors for it.
You know that that experience,
look,
the Jujitsu things started because on the podcast I was describing for the last
podcast I was describing flying to you has described it was just shopping dog
fighting too.
Yeah.
And you're like,
dude,
that sounds exactly like Jujitsu.
And that's kind of what sparked my interest was w is there a way to kind of
replicate those experiences that I had that I know I can't do it in an airplane
anymore,
but can I,
can I replicate that in some other way?
And that was what was intriguing to me.
Um,
and that was what got me on the path of that.
But look,
I already said this,
I didn't think the magnitude of the panic of,
Oh God,
I'm running out of time.
I have so much more to do was going to get bigger over time.
And that is sort of what like Jujitsu is,
is,
and,
and I,
again,
I think we've had this conversation,
well,
I've made fun of you on this podcast when you weren't here.
Yeah.
Have you be,
you know,
you sent me a tax like,
Bro,
this is horrible.
Like,
oh,
well,
what's,
what's going on?
You're like,
well,
I'm never going to be like really,
really,
really good at Jujitsu.
Like around your whatever.
You're 46 years old if you know.
Yeah,
get good.
You know,
It's all good.
Yeah,
no,
certainly.
Um,
I,
I think the messages and the lesson for me is,
is that a reminder of,
of something that I did know,
something I have known throughout my life of that feeling of the clock is
running.
You're on the clock right now.
You don't know when that clock's going to end,
but I'm going to tell you,
Rau,
you're on it.
And every second that you're not grinding on that clock,
you lose it.
And
okay,
there's a point where complacency will try to sneak in.
The complacency will try to crawl up and go,
Dude,
you've been crushing it.
Look at what you've done.
And that voice can kind of get loud and they can kind of tell you like,
dude,
it's time to kind of turn the corner and coast a little bit,
Kinda,
Kinda glide just a little bit.
You're good.
Um,
and I think the best thing that's happened to me is that exposure to,
okay,
echelon front exposure to it,
to,
to the,
to the team,
and exposure to Jujitsu in a way of not like,
oh,
am I going to be some world champion and Jay,
it's that bro.
The more you know,
the more you learn,
the less you actually,
no,
because learning just means like,
oh,
there's more out there.
So you go from one to two,
but what's available is a hundred to a thousand and you get to three and a
thousand turns into 10,000 and Jujitsu is infinite.
And so every time I get to whatever the next step is,
the next level,
all it really does is,
is this just somebody opening door go,
oh,
it's actually bigger.
So it's almost like you're getting worse.
You know,
if you do the math,
I think I'm now at level four and above a million.
You're like yesterday there was only four moves.
I didn't know.
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
Today there's 40 moves they don't know.
And the other thing is from,
from,
okay,
for dog fighting in an aircraft,
right.
It seems like there would be some limitation without a doubt.
Okay.
And we haven't,
we,
you and I have not had this conversation,
but I've had those thoughts.
They're absolutely,
absolutely is a limit.
There's only so many things that you can do.
Um,
and that's actually not true,
you know,
and,
and in an aircraft,
you know,
just,
just by constraints of time,
I mean,
you can't,
you can't go up and dog fight for four hours a day every now you do that in top
gun for,
for a few years.
But the opponents that you have,
well,
I guess you're going to get to the other stuff,
but that's it.
That's as good as you're gonna get.
Yeah.
But Jujitsu,
you can do that for looking at here,
the parallels are undeniable.
The parallels there,
and you saw that right away.
You and I talked about that.
There no question.
That has been the most intriguing thing for me is that it's,
I'm able to replicate those feelings.
But the unlimited nature of how of what's out there.
If I had a guy in a hornet that I was going to go do BFM with and he was,
we were going to do these,
this maneuvers and he'd be like,
I like to do this.
When I'm defensive and it wasn't exactly what he's supposed to do,
he was going to lose every single time.
I'm like,
Oh,
you,
you're not going to do the best method in this situation.
Good.
I'm going to savage you.
Jujitsu is not,
it's not like that.
Yeah.
If there is no,
this is what works and everything else is inferior and we have the geometry,
we have the math,
we have the science,
the physics,
and we actually at top gun through a ton of effort and try it on.
They're actually figured out this is what you need to do here.
This is how you create the most amount of closure.
These are all the things you do to maximize your aircraft,
and so if somebody deviates from that,
it's just better for you.
That's not true.
Yes.
It's been so broken down and so study that there's no possibility that someone
could come up with something and go,
oh,
I came up with something new.
No,
it's not happening.
Nope.
Not Happening.
And,
and when you're,
when you're,
when you're a top gun,
I would love to somebody to try something new.
Go for it.
Yeah.
Do,
do your worst.
Come up with your best game plan.
Because I know what you need to do in this situation.
And if you don't do that,
you're just giving me opportunity.
That's what you're doing.
And so there is a level of that in Jujitsu where,
you know,
they're all going to put your arms up here,
there's all the,
you're going to give up your back and there's all these things that you can't
do.
But for instance,
Jeffy Glover,
he'll give up his back and then he's rolling away from you or dean lister,
he's,
you're getting him in a triangle,
you think,
and then you're getting your guard passing or getting smashed.
So there's,
there's times where the things
that you don't expect someone to do,
they do.
And it's problematic.
Yeah.
And,
and I want to be very careful.
Um,
I'm so new at this that I almost should not be telling you what I think I know
about this,
but the glide path to get from seeing the inside of an [inaudible] for the first
time in to being right at the very apex of that community,
six,
seven years.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That's seven years from,
I'm going to introduce you to this airplane now and you know,
you know how to fly,
but now I'm gonna introduce you to a combat aircraft for the first time in your
life,
a real combat machine.
You're going to get in that thing.
I got there in 1998.
First Time I set foot in an team,
I got to top gun in 2000,
uh,
2002 I left in 2005.
So I would say I was kind of at my apex in 2005.
So from 98 to oh five,
that's how long it took me to be at the top of,
of,
of that world.
Am I going to be?
Can you imagine like the best guys
Judici the guys that have been doing it for five to six years?
Well,
what you have to do is you,
there are some anomalies out there.
Yeah.
There's guys that are incredibly,
the carnal natural hazards.
And also you'd have to take someone and say,
okay,
this is your job because that was your job.
That's a big piece.
Hey,
this is your job.
And that happens.
Some kids get into Jujitsu and they're like,
oh,
I'm going to sleep on the mat.
All I'm going to do is train Bj Penn and got his black belt and did well.
Did he win the world's and after three years?
I don't think so.
But you know,
in three years got his black out and he was a legit blackbelt.
Someone was asking on social media the other day,
Hey,
is this guy legit?
He's,
he seems to have calmed his black belt,
got his black belt from dawn and her in a short period of time.
Oh,
you mean the judo?
A Olympian.
Olympic silver medalist.
Yeah.
He might have some skills.
He might be able to get up there pretty quick.
Yes.
Uh,
for that answer.
Yes.
That dude is legit.
You can get your black belt,
you can get your back blackbelt pretty quickly.
If you have a bunch of natural talent,
maybe you have some kind of base wrestling,
judo,
something like that.
And then you make it your job.
Yeah.
You can get your,
you can get really good really fast.
Yeah.
But yeah,
basically if your mind is like addicted to it in one way or another.
And then you have some prerequisites like you know,
the Geo and the,
yeah,
the Martinez brothers.
They had breakdancing that a lot of the same stuff,
you know,
and that kind of went along with their style and I would go so far as to say
this is,
this is a guests.
I would go so far as to say that most people that have their black belt in
Jujitsu,
we're in the obsessed mode at some point in their life.
Makes Sense.
That's what I'm going to say.
Sure.
I cannot disagree with that.
Right.
You,
have you ever known someone that's a black belt that that was not at least for a
period of three years was just,
that's all they thought about.
I don't know of any.
No,
they,
they were just into Jujitsu
real hardcore.
Yeah,
it's true.
And then maybe they grow out of a little bit or some,
whatever.
Some people lives,
keep training,
training hard.
That's how it is.
One of the things that you did.
Uh,
and this is going,
I hate to cycle back to the podcast again,
but I'm going to do it real quick.
So I had a,
I had a note about it and it's something that you and I've talked about several
times from Tom five came on the podcast,
purple heart art,
you know,
served in World War II,
Korea,
Vietnam,
purple heart,
World War II,
Korea,
Vietnam Battalion Commander in world war or in Vietnam,
a company commander in Korea and I think tank platoon commander,
a little road to tank platoon commander in World War Two.
So if that's your resume,
what's our,
I'm sorry,
uh,
engineer and,
and so,
so there's his resume,
but it was really interesting.
So when he came on the podcast and we were talking about,
you know,
leadership and stuff like that and he gives this answer of,
we were talking around the subject of,
you know,
how do you get someone out,
how do you get your people listen to you?
And he says,
Hey,
you tell them to do it and they do it.
And I remember you and I talking and afterwards he was like,
man,
that was not a,
that was not a Jocko answer of like,
Hey,
you know,
hey listen,
you've got to build a relationship with people.
You've got to,
you got to get their trust,
you've got to earn their respect.
You got to,
you got to treat them how you want to be treated.
And then we,
if you explain to them why the mission is important and they believe in the
mission and they know that you're going to back them up,
then they're going to back you up when you need dead to do something.
Like,
I have this whole thing,
right?
Yeah.
This is big problem.
It's this big,
uh,
dance you got to go through as a leader.
And,
and I think to myself,
I've got this figured out.
And so he goes,
no,
I tell people to do it.
I'm like,
man,
that's Kinda,
that's kind of a bummer.
I'm thinking,
what?
I'm gonna tell echo to edit that out.
Right.
Just kidding.
But then this was the cool part was then he,
he continued to talk about it and he gave just the most perfect answer.
The things that,
everything that we say all the time,
everything that we talk about national on front,
everything that I talk about them,
those podcasts,
he gave it all.
Yeah.
He,
he,
he really just did it in reverse order of conversations that we have.
We explained sometimes that in in really challenging environments,
sometimes you've got to say,
Hey,
go make this happen and you got to have your people say Roger that and they go
make it happen.
You gotta be able to do that sometimes.
But the only way for that to work in those really demanding difficult,
challenging environments is to go way back before and build all those
relationships and create all that trust and do all those things.
So when people go,
Dave just said,
go make this happen.
When you don't make it happen,
we'll ask questions later.
He just went to that part because I almost set it up for that because the
question I was asking him was,
how do you get a guy to jump out of your tank under fire to fix the turn?
In his mind,
that's the like there's rounds hitting the tank,
Ping,
and the,
the tank track falls off and someone's got to get out there and fix it.
And he goes to the junior guy and he's like,
you gotta get out there and fix it.
And so it was,
he just did that whole thing in reverse order.
He went to that part and then,
and I remember thinking like,
man,
that was kind of a bummer answer.
It really wasn't expecting that.
And I was like,
you just tell him what to do.
And then I didn't that work for me.
Yeah.
Uh,
I might have to change the way.
Yeah.
So when he started to go and I remember that feeling of like,
oh he,
and now he's starting to explain it and I looked at you a couple of times and he
did the whole thing and he,
he,
he speaks very plain language too.
And he just sort of distilled it all down.
It was like,
you have to take care of your people,
you have to treat your people well.
And if you do,
they will do the same for you.
And if you don't guess what,
when you say jump out of the tank under fire,
they're going to say no.
That was the best part is when he actually came all the way back around and
said,
if you just think you're just going to tell someone to get out of a tank or a
fire and they don't believe in what's going on and they don't trust you and you
haven't taken care of them,
they're not going anywhere.
Every time I hear all the people you've had on the podcast,
I know the stories are different,
but they're all saying the same thing.
They're all saying the same thing and their own little nuance way,
their own little experience,
but it's always the same thing.
And that was of all of them my favorite because I got to know Tom before the
podcast and we got to talk quite a bit.
Uh,
and I got to spend time with them before we went live on that recording.
Um,
so I enjoyed that one the most,
but it's everybody's saying the same thing.
Move made a huge point about that without caring about your people,
you got to care about your people.
Again,
these are guys that were due that were leading
draftees.
Yeah.
Vietnam draft these and I went off of this and then we were the other day.
Is there any more hostile workforce in the,
okay,
maybe not my history of the world,
but is there,
this is right up there.
You got guys that have been,
cause it's,
you know,
if you're a World War II and you get drafted,
guess what?
The country's behind the war.
You're going to be a hero.
You're fighting against Nazis or Jay imperial,
Japanese that are evil humans and you're on board for the big win.
We get that.
That's what happens.
Korea like not quite so clear,
but guess what?
We still even remember World War II.
So guess what?
We're going to go get in the game.
Yeah.
Vietnam,
they straight up don't believe in the war.
They just straight up don't believe in the war there,
there against their will under threat of prison.
They show up there and these are the people you're in charge of.
And this is the answer I give all the time now
for when people ask me about millennials,
people are like,
oh,
you know,
we,
we got millennials and they got a bad attitude.
Oh really?
That the millennials have a bad attitude.
Compare that to a drafted Vietnam soldier,
and here's the thing that I realized because,
and when I pulled that,
when I started going through hack again,
uh,
about face get and I started reading that,
I realized that you got to change your perspective as a leader.
It's not just,
it's not just,
hey,
because we simplified it.
I like,
well,
if you're millennials aren't doing what you want,
it's your fault.
That's,
that's a simplification of it because what you really got to do is you got to
shift your mindset a little bit and say like,
what?
Wait a second.
How do I take advantage of,
that's what Hackworth was doing.
Hackworth was saying,
wait a second.
How do I take advantage of these guys?
Guess what?
They're going to question me if I do something wrong.
They're going to report things that aren't done correctly.
They're going to say no.
If I plan something stupid,
is that a bad thing?
Let me think about it.
Actually,
no,
that's actually not a bad thing.
So if you've got a millennial that's like,
hey,
if I don't like the leadership here,
I'm leaving the company.
Guess what?
Let's get that person some good leadership.
And you've got to a millennial that says,
hey,
if I don't understand why we're doing what we're doing,
I don't know.
I don't care.
I'm not going to do it.
Okay,
well let's explain to that person.
Why should they have a full understanding of what it is we're trying to get
done?
You shift your mindset a little bit about the whole deal and you ended up in a
much better position,
but it's a perspective shift.
Yeah,
you,
it's the same thing.
We always say it's not just take ownership of it.
So it's,
if you,
if you say,
oh my millennials aren't doing what I need him to do,
that's my fault.
That doesn't make them to start doing what you need them to do.
You actually have to make changes in your leadership style to adapt to this
attitude that's coming your way.
And at the end of the day,
if you do that,
you'll have someone that's smart,
that's motivated,
that will get on board with the program and we'll do a great job.
Yeah,
just like drafting like a draftee.
And when,
when we see it in,
in leaders all the time,
they present it like
we can't leave these people,
these,
these unsolvable problem.
It is a problem and we're,
we're going downhill at supersonic speeds.
And when you do what you just said in trying to change that perspective and then
put it in comparison to the story of the draftees,
they're almost a little embarrassed.
Like No.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's one of those answers.
When I give that answer,
I,
I have to soften it a little bit cause I just can't
like,
hey,
these guys were taking,
I don't,
I don't throw this in their face of like,
hey,
these guys were taking draftees that didn't even believe in the war and we're
going to get killed.
You're like,
hey,
you're asking someone to stay late.
And the Tuesday night.
Yeah.
That's what you're asking for.
They were asking them to patrol through a mine written jungle.
Right.
Not to mention
this person is actually interviewed or your company applied for a job,
wants to be there.
Yeah.
There there's a clear difference in generations is something to think about,
but nobody force this person to join your dean under threat and under threat of
prison.
Yeah.
And you see that in the,
when the recognition hits,
you can see it of like,
oh yeah,
no,
you're right.
This actually is a very solvable problem.
It just takes some work on my part.
Um,
and I mean that's true with everything.
Yeah.
We got,
I mean we obviously we have all kinds of companies out there that we work with
now and their workforce is now becoming all millennials and their front line
people right now at a company,
the frontline people are all millennials.
And so if you don't figure this out,
who,
who are you going to hire?
Yeah.
Who are you going to hire?
I mean,
it's like being in Vietnam.
You,
you were going to have draftees.
If you don't figure that out.
And that's the other thing is you hear the bad leaders from Vietnam that will,
that will say,
oh the draftees were horrible.
I couldn't work with them.
They were,
you know,
they didn't do want to do their job.
Stickman maybe you should look in the mirror a little bit.
Yeah.
And that the,
the,
the best part about that is when you asked,
same thing with Tom Fife.
Yup.
Cause he's like,
that's all.
That's all we ever had.
He was almost like they understand the questions.
That was our military back then when I was in,
when he was in the army.
It was like I didn't,
I couldn't tell you who was a draftee and who wasn't.
I didn't,
I didn't know the difference that I,
there are people,
they're human beings and I treated them like that.
And so the,
the,
just the idea that you would segregate those two,
the draftees and the,
and,
and the,
the volunteer military was immediate indication of what kind of leader you had.
And these guys were like,
I don't,
first of all to understand the question,
all we had was draftees at the time we,
everybody was being drafted in the second,
didn't matter to me.
They didn't care.
I didn't care.
We had a mission to do.
I expand on the impact and the importance of the mission.
Told them their role in that mission and what would happen if they did or didn't
do it.
I cared about them and we just did it and that's my favorite part about Tom five
is he's,
he's just a plain spoken guy.
He doesn't have this really flowery,
articulate language.
He's just like,
oh yeah,
no,
I treated my people really well and when I asked them to do stuff,
they did it.
That's kind of,
that's kind of it.
That's a pretty awesome leadership advice.
It is to your people really well and when the time comes that you need to do
something that they need to do something for you,
they're going to do,
I'm going to do it.
Take care of your people and your people are going to take care of you.
Yeah.
We started about a year to hear your dear,
thanks.
Take care of your people.
How about,
how about we start with that one and then your people are going to take care of
you too.
Yeah.
We,
I think we,
we forget those lessons sometimes.
You know,
it's human capital.
It's like,
no,
they're,
they're people.
They're just people.
It's does treat them like people treat them like you treat anybody else.
And you know,
some of those fundamental lessons,
you know,
across leadership.
I think in a lot of ways I was lucky to,
to,
to see that modeled early my career.
Uh,
and I think a lot of times we end up on the path of,
of who we're following on day one and they can take you down the wrong road if
you've got the wrong people.
Um,
but when you see it in other people and they treat you that way and that feeling
of,
Oh,
this guy,
this guy really cares about me.
This guy really is invested in me being successful in me having a good,
good life and a good career.
It's,
it's not hard to recognize like,
oh that that's how,
that's what I should do.
And the exact opposite is true.
And like when the people,
and I worked for people that I despised and I despise because that,
how they treated me,
how they treated other people and just very evident like don't be like that.
It doesn't work.
I'll,
I'll be in a group of leaders we're doing to working with the company.
I've done this many times where I'll set it up with,
hey,
who here has had someone in your life as that would,
that,
that was in charge of you that invested in you and took care of you?
Raise your hand.
And everyone raises their hand and,
or 99% of the people will raise their hand if not 100% of people raise your
hand.
Cause that's,
you know,
usually we're talking to leaders in the company and so the leaders have made
progress somehow and they've made progress because someone at some point taught
them and took them under their wing and cared about them.
And you know,
so I say,
who,
who's had someone that cared about them and invested in them and took care of
them,
took care of you and everyone raises their hand and how did that feel?
And everyone says,
oh,
I had it felt awesome,
but what would you do for that leader?
I do anything for him.
Why don't you be that leader?
Then why don't you be that leader and take care of those people properly?
And you'll end up with a team.
They'll do anything for you,
not for selfish reasons,
cause they'll see right through that.
You've got to be doing it for the team when you want the team to do well,
then they'll do anything for you.
Yeah,
I think that's a really important lesson for any leader out there for,
for leadership in general is how obvious what you're doing is to other people
and whatever thing you're trying to hide or whatever the thing you're trying to
cover up or,
or,
or something you're trying to mask,
he sees,
everybody sees it,
everybody sees right through it.
And you know,
we asked the same question is,
okay,
what would you want your subordinates to do to you?
Come up and say,
it's not my fault.
I didn't have anything and this isn't,
this isn't my fault.
I couldn't do anything about it.
You didn't send me up to win.
Or would you like someone to walk them and say,
Hey boss,
I screwed this up.
There's a couple of things I could have done differently.
Here's what I learned and you know what,
I'm going to do this next time and I'm gonna get this right and I'm going to fix
this.
And you say,
he said those two.
So really obvious to different scenarios and ask him,
what would you like to have from your subordinates?
Uh,
100% of the people are going to go,
I want the guy that comes in and says,
Hey,
it's my fault.
I'm going to fix her zone.
It's super obvious.
And then the very next question is,
why aren't you doing that with your boss?
Why do you not think that your boss has having this same feeling as you would
have your subordinates?
And that recognition of everybody sees exactly what you're doing that's
uncomfortable for people.
Yeah.
The uncomfortable part is it's hard for people,
I guess.
I guess we think that if you're my boss,
I think you're not as smart as me and I think,
well,
he's just going to blame me when I come in and say it's my fault.
You're going to go,
yeah,
I know.
That's why I'm firing.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
no,
people are smarter than that and no one wants to hear excuses.
No one wants to hear excuses.
Yeah.
You know what?
Sometimes people screw things up so bad that they're going to get fired.
I was just going to say that like,
and guess what?
If you go to make excuses,
guess what?
You're still only going to get fired.
You're going to take what ever limited chance of maybe salvaging that at the
last second of like,
Hey boss,
hang on,
let me just,
if you do that,
you're just guaranteeing the outcome.
Lafe talks about that.
When he was the Xo at,
at,
uh,
seal team and he says,
you know,
he'd get a guy that was,
something was going wrong and a platoon and a guy would come in and say,
you know,
it's not my fault,
my chiefs no good or my Lpo doesn't know what he's doing.
It like,
okay,
you're fired.
And the next part comes in and says,
Hey,
I'm not doing a good job as a leader.
Here's the things I'm going to change.
Like,
okay,
yeah,
we'll keep working on it.
Let me know if you have any questions,
let me know if I can help you out.
Let's get you the support you need.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a number.
That's extreme ownership.
Da.
Yeah,
sorry.
W we would,
we would have bored sometimes for,
for pilots,
you know,
performance boards and,
and we would review a lot of material and a lot of times you'd,
you'd have to fire somebody.
I mean,
don't like doing it,
but in aviation you just,
it's a lot of times it's their whole,
it's the dream week.
Same thing with the teams.
Like they dreamed about this as a kid and you know that you are ending their
life's dream,
dream crusher,
you're going to,
you're going to do that.
Not to mention a paycheck gone.
Yeah.
Well like for officers in the seal teams a lot of times is or retirement or
whatever.
It's it's a bad situation.
Yeah,
it's,
it's massive impact.
It's a huge deal to do that and you take that very seriously.
When you're in a position where you are going to,
you're going to be one of the deciding factors in whether that person stays or
goes.
Anytime you get to that point where your mind like,
Hey,
the best thing is to get rid of this guy and if you bring them in for this or
that final interview,
that final interaction,
the guarantee way to seal your fate,
the guarantee way to ensure what they've already kind of concluded because
that's why they're bringing in in the first place is to not take any
responsibility to not take any donors.
That is 100% guaranteed.
Now,
it doesn't mean that you might just not be able to,
you might not have the technical skills and the capability.
Sometimes you're going to get fired and sometimes your mistake is so egregious
and does so much damage.
Yeah,
you gotta go,
you're going to get fired,
but even then,
the,
the best thing you can do,
the best thing you can do is to take ownership of all that and be like,
Hey,
boss,
I understand.
I'm sorry.
Or you can go the other route and you could start to throw everybody under the
bus.
And you know what?
This is what's interesting.
There are some people,
and I've talked
to many of them over the years,
many of them,
they don't make that connection.
They literally don't make that connection.
They don't make the connection.
They're looking at their boss and they're saying,
hey,
this wasn't my fault.
It was my,
whoever it was my subordinate leader.
It was the maintenance guy.
It was this,
it was that.
They literally don't make the connection that if you're in charge of something
or the,
you're responsible for something and it goes wrong,
you're responsible for it.
Yeah.
And they cannot make that connection.
You feel like you're,
you just,
I would watch when we would have a bad seal platoon going through my training,
and I'd bring in a,
uh,
a platoon commander or a platoon chief and they would literally like,
like an assault chief.
So the guy is in charge of the assault,
he's in charge of the assault,
and it's like,
hey,
all your men went to the wrong target.
What happened?
Well,
it was briefed wrong.
it was this,
well,
we marked the target wasn't marked correctly.
The battle maps.
I mean,
literally just,
you could come up with 20 excuses and you know what?
They're all bell makes sense.
They're like,
hey,
someone made someone put the wrong number on the brief and everyone heard the
wrong number.
And they looked at their battle map and they went to that building.
Okay.
That's what happened.
Whose fault is it?
It's not the guy that made the battle map.
You're in charge.
You're in charge of the assault team,
you're in charge of the assault team.
This is,
this is your fault.
And it would,
I would sometimes I would just,
actually,
I would hardly ever say this was your fault.
I would milk.
I wouldn't try and milk it out of them.
I would be like,
so we'll,
we'll,
I mean,
but still like who was in charge of the assaults?
If only we had a guy in charge of that process and they say,
well,
you know what I mean?
Either you see a soul chief,
you know,
you can't expect to do the guided to be confirming that every single guy knows
where the target is revealing.
Okay.
So you're not responsible for getting the men to the target as the,
you're not responsible for the assault as the assault chief is what I'm hearing.
So it's really horrible when you see that someone can't make the connection.
And what this is,
this is another cool thing on social media.
I see this a lot.
Guys will hit me up,
girls will hit me up.
Uh,
something went wrong with a client I stepped in.
I took ownership,
they thanked me,
problem solved,
got it squared away.
I can't,
people are surprised.
People are surprised that it works.
And again,
just to make sure everybody knows
that that alone doesn't work,
you still have to problem solve the problem with you because with the client,
right?
Right you,
you,
you gave them what they needed late or it's going to be late and now you say
it's my fault.
That doesn't mean that you don't need to get it to him asap and make up some
corrective measures and lower the price to do something so that it makes up for
the problem.
But the worst thing
you can say is,
well,
you didn't specify exactly what you wanted it in the order and therefore we
couldn't get you what you wanted on time.
Okay,
we're never coming back for business again and we're angry this whole time and
I'm going to short you money when we pay you in any ways.
A five.
Yeah,
let's make it,
let's make it the customers and the clients fault.
Let's do that.
And it gets back to something you said earlier about the conversation about the
millennials is just for a minute detached to take a step back real quick and
just put yourself in their position.
What do they want to hear?
This client that things went sideways,
that what they needed from you didn't happen.
They didn't get it delivered on time.
It didn't work the way it's supposed to work.
Or worse.
You gave it to something and it created a problem for their customers down the
line.
What do they want to hear from you right now?
You are to them go and the allergy that should come from hearing and excuses.
The allergic reaction to hearing someone tell you it's their fault or,
or it's not.
It's not their fault.
It's somebody else's fault.
A hundred out of 100 times you should understand and,
and the point is that that's still hard to do.
It's still hard.
And that bridge is,
is hard to cross.
And reading the book isn't enough.
It,
it sets the table and expose you to it.
But I think it comes with everything you,
you have to get inside it,
you have to live it.
But the thing of it is,
is the first time you do it,
the first time you do it,
because it works every single time.
Once someone,
once you get to that tipping point,
once the,
the domino falls,
I think it's then it's like magic,
then it's just things are just happening on their own and all your people go,
no,
no.
This is,
this is definitely what we're going to do here.
We're going to tell them exactly what we did wrong,
how we're gonna solve the problem we're going to do to fix it and to make sure
it doesn't happen again.
And it deescalates the client is like,
Oh man,
I was really hoping we could fight and argue and you're not letting me do that
now because what you're saying is everything I actually really need to hear and
I'm forced to say,
okay,
let's go solve this problem.
And when you see it from the inside out and you start to do it,
that tipping point,
it happens quick.
It just takes a lot of time to get there and there's so much resistance that
human nature resistance to oh there.
There's no way I'm taking the blame for this.
I've actually got a bunch of good reasons that I can give you a why.
It's not really my fault and I'm going to kind of sell like,
Hey,
boss,
you know,
those guys aren't,
they're not the,
they're not the best guys.
You know,
this is not the best team here.
Here's,
here's a,
let's call it a drill or a,
or a coaching,
I'll call it that.
A coaching.
When the next time you get into a situation and you write down,
or you can take the,
the excuses and the reasons that you come up with,
look at them and then figure out how they work,
how those things were actually your fault and or how you could have prevented
them.
Because a lot of times it's like,
here's,
here's the one.
Uh,
hey boss,
we didn't get the mission accomplished because the weather rolled in and we
couldn't launch on the mission.
That's,
that's the problem.
Now we all know that we don't control the weather.
So when you say you write the problem down,
we failed the mission because we didn't control the weather.
We can't control the weather.
That's why we failed the mission.
That's my excuse.
That's a,
that's a logical reason.
There's that's,
that's a,
that's a legitimate excuse,
but don't use it.
What you do is you say,
what could I have done to have controlled the weather?
Okay,
I don't care.
okay,
wait,
I can't control the weather.
What could I have done?
I could've come up with a contingency plan.
I could have come up.
We could have staged in a better place.
So then you go to the boss and you say,
look boss,
here's what happened.
The weather went south really bad.
That was a problem.
But it's a problem that I should have done a better job taking care of.
What I should've done was I should have had a contingency plan.
I should have staged closer to the target area that I could have taken vehicles
instead of helicopters.
That's my fault.
From now on,
I will absolutely have a secondary plan.
This won't happen again.
We can't control the weather,
but we can control how we plan and how we execute and this won't happen again.
There you go.
So you take the most outrageous thing that you know you can't control.
You figure out a way to control it and you take ownership of that thing and it
is going fade.
It's gonna make your life so much better.
And by the way,
the next time you have a mission and you plan that contingency and you actually
execute and implement what you said you're going to do,
guess what?
You will accomplish the mission.
There's a whole part of ownership that preempts the problem.
If you've got someone that knows,
if I know that I can make an excuse,
then guess what?
I'm not going to set things up properly.
If I don't set things up properly more often or more often than the other way,
I will fail to to execute what I'm supposed to execute.
If you have an excuse,
right?
Same.
Same thing with you as an individual human being.
Have you as an individual human being,
if you got some excuses that you can throw out there that you can say,
I had no control over that,
then you know what you say,
okay,
what are my contingency plans?
What could I have planned differently?
Let's eliminate those excuses.
Take ownership of your freaking life.
Yeah,
and in that situation too,
when you're talking about this example of the weather and if you as a leader
actually accept the excuse like,
Hey boss,
I that that storm rolled in and just crushed us,
and you're like,
yeah,
yeah.
Out of your control,
there's no way he have solved for this problem.
It's unsolvable.
What have you just guaranteed it will happen every single time the weather rules
in you set that in stone.
It will never be different.
The weather will crush you every single time.
Or You could go,
I don't know,
look at your weather app and go,
we got to go six early in stage
and we're going to walk in and it works both ways at the at and if you accept
those excuses,
you're now doing that.
That's a free pass for eater on that.
The weather is actually something we can't control.
So that was now something that is okay,
why we fail.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
I understand that it's hard.
I know that feeling and that,
but when you see it get to the other side and you see people doing like don't,
that was sort of like a turning point for me mentally because I,
as I,
as I grew up and I said to myself,
you know,
I understood that I needed to take responsibility for what was happening,
but the turning point for me came when I realized that no matter what happened,
if I'm the guy in charge,
we need to get this thing done.
That's the way it is.
And when you,
when you have that thought in your brain,
the preparation you do is so much more solid because there's no way out.
There's no way out.
So you've got to execute.
Yeah.
When,
when leaders see the world like that,
when they see it that way,
they'd just work until the problem gets solved.
They just do everything they need to do until they find a way to fix the problem
to solve it.
And when they don't think like that,
they there,
there are outlets there off ramps to be like,
ah,
can't do it.
Can't do it,
can't do it,
can't do it.
And we used to,
we call that the excuse matrix,
that's the word you're like,
oh,
it comes the,
excuse me.
Checks.
Yeah.
And then,
and then the other part of this you've got to remember is that this doesn't
mean,
this doesn't mean that I'm going to bang my head up against the wall 47 times to
accomplish the mission.
That it's like,
oh,
guess what apart part of this is,
hey,
I didn't plan it.
Well,
I made some mistakes I didn't calculate correctly and now we are not going to
get this done.
And that's the way it is.
And so I'm not saying you continue to beat your head against the wall.
47 to 47 is the limit.
Don't do 48 when you've done 48 and you've gone too far,
you're not going to get through the wall.
Trust me.
If you can get through a wall,
it'll get through by the 47th headbutt after that is not happening.
So you've got to take a little,
uh,
you got to look for the alternate route.
Yeah,
so there's a difference.
There's a difference between we're going to get this done no matter what,
and we're going to get this done.
No matter what
you do.
Sometimes you got to back off.
Sometimes you gotta re attack.
Yeah.
Sometimes you got to reassess your plan and somebody to,
to get,
you got to go a different direction.
And when it all costs doesn't mean I'm going to charge that elevated machine gun
deaths through open ground,
wave after wave after wave,
it means you're going to do something else.
It doesn't mean you're going to abandon the attack on that position,
but you might actually do it a different way and it may be like,
my plan sucked.
Here's all the things that I learned about my stupid plan.
Anybody got an,
and maybe I can get some help.
He does.
I've seen this before.
This is what we did.
That's a good idea.
Let's do that.
Plant and you know,
we,
again,
we could talk about this for a long time,
but I think that natural tendency to be exposed as,
as someone who doesn't know something to be exposed as someone who doesn't have
all the answers to expose,
as a leader who doesn't know everything,
I'm going to let you in on a little secret.
Everybody already knows that.
Everybody knows that you don't know everything.
And if you try to act like you do it,
we'll make it 10 times worse than just saying,
I actually don't know what to do here.
Or I made a mistake here.
When you make a mistake,
everybody knows it.
Your subordinates know at your peers,
know what your boss has,
no it.
And the worst thing you can do is to tell them that you didn't.
That's why being insecure in your leadership capabilities is a downward spiral
because the more insecure you are,
the more you try and manipulate,
maintain everything,
and keep everything under your wraps and do everything your way.
And that's how it is.
So when you're insecure as a leader and that's another,
that's another thing that takes a little bit of a leap of faith.
That's another like progression that I personally made.
I personally made a novel,
I can't remember when,
but when I was like,
you know what?
It's okay.
I'm not going to be,
I'm not the best in the world,
and everybody knows that in.
The more I tried to act like that,
the more obvious that's going to be.
And the minute you say that,
the minute you recognize that people are going,
hmm,
okay,
he might not be the best,
but at least he knows that as opposed to he's not the best and he thinks he is.
That's a nightmare.
That was a work for that guy.
And the,
the best part about what you just said is that that's something that we all had
to learn.
That's something we'll have to figure out at some point in our life.
None of us were born of like,
oh no,
I knew all this at birth.
It's it from these giant errors that we've made are giant mistakes with these
giant realizations.
Like I've been doing it wrong and everybody has to figure that out.
And then,
and that right there,
that is one of the most gratifying things about what we do now is that this gap
that we talked about earlier,
this little gap between like how do you read something,
you read something and then how do you get that thing out of it?
How do you extract that vital piece of information that's in there?
How do you do that?
How do you tell?
Look,
it's like when you're a kid and you don't listen to your parents,
right?
You just,
how do you get that?
He'd close that gap.
And what's awesome about what we do now is that we get to close that gap with
people we'd get,
I mean,
I see it on a daily basis,
on a daily basis with the leaders that we work with.
You get to see their eyes open up and you go,
boom,
they get it.
Now.
Everything we just talked about,
which know,
which we had to learn
over time and extrapolate from our experiences.
And then on top of that go through horrible situations where we failed as
leaders and we've figured out a way to say,
look,
here it is.
Here's how it works.
And to see people's eyes open up and then to see the performance,
that's the best to see the performance go through the roof as the leader.
And then of course when the leader starts doing well,
then the leaders start doing well.
And when all the leaders start doing well,
guess what?
Now we have a winning team.
Yeah.
To emphasize what you said,
that eyes opening,
that's a literal thing.
Like they don't,
it's not a metaphor.
You look at them and when you finally get it to click,
when you,
when it,
their eyes actually open up and they sit up straight and they kind of sit back a
little bit and there is a moment,
a physical moment,
you recognize that they got it.
Yup.
And when you see that,
and you can actually sit in an audience,
when you,
when you're,
when you're talking to a group,
like maybe multiple leaders on a team and you were around a conference table and
you're interacting and you bring up a particular example that they're dealing
with,
you lay out the different possible scenarios and the one that is obviously the
right one,
and they go,
oh,
oh my God,
when they get that,
that feeling is unbelievable.
It's the best part about this is when they get it.
But you literally see that happen.
Yeah.
Uh,
and that is,
yeah.
Awesome.
And that's that for me.
So when I,
my last three years when I was in the teams and I was working,
running the training for the west coast seal teams,
and I got to see that,
I got to see that with these young leaders and just our abs.
It's,
it's in my head,
right?
I gotta,
I gotta tell this story.
There's a young kid who I know who's an awesome guy and I didn't really know him
that well at the time,
but he was kind of like a pipe header and a platoon and there's total mayhem
going on,
total chaos going on.
And I just like go over to him and like his,
you know,
his platoon commander was simulated dead and blah,
blah,
blah and doing chief was simulated at an Lpo,
wasn't making a call and it's total chaos ma'am.
And I walk over to him and I'm like,
hey man.
And he's like,
yeah.
And,
and I go,
hey man,
Bro,
are you going to do something about this right here?
And,
and that was all he needed to hear.
All he needed to hear was like that guy that was in charge of all this training
was telling me like was asking me a question.
He was questioning me and saying,
are you going to do something about this?
His eyes opened up and he said,
Oh hell yes I am.
And boom,
he starts stepped up,
started making calls and the whole,
the whole paradigm in the situation completely changed cause he's,
he stepped up and led.
And so I got to see that then and I get to see it now.
So that's a cool thing.
Yeah it is.
And the stories about my experience at top gun or art are identical.
And when,
when you go on a missions and they suck and you get savaged and it's just
terrible,
okay guys come back and,
and they're miserable.
Losing sucks man.
It sucks when you have this
huge plenty,
you go out there and you get savaged it sucks.
And then when you go through this whole thing and there's that recognition and
they change the way they breathed,
that changed the way they train,
the change,
the way they do things with their guys.
And they go out and they come back and,
and when you dominate that feeling of coming back from a flight and you just
dominated,
that's a really good feeling.
And so when,
when they do this and they start winning like you've just described you at that
team,
then they start winning dude Ben then than they are then they're thoroughbreds,
they're running under on that and you get as a leader,
get to back off and just get to watch them go dominate that feeling of being
successful.
When you implement these things as a leader,
that's the best feeling in the world.
And when you see that on for from your juniors,
more from your subordinate,
from your team,
and you see them go do that,
there is nothing better than that.
And then you get,
well we get to see,
we can see,
I used to get to see this,
he to them,
you get to see it start to take hold of.
Yeah,
and but Echo,
you've talked about this where I'm like,
where you,
you know what I'm doing
with you?
You know what I'm doing?
You sat here through hundreds of hours of me talking about how I'm going to
treat someone on my team and you're like,
you know what I'm doing?
And it still works.
100% and what's cool is when,
when you know what the person's doing,
when you know what your leaders doing and it still works,
then you go,
you know what,
I'm going to do it too.
And that's how it spreads throughout these ones out spreads,
because we'll get it.
So let's say,
I dunno,
I make a mistake or something like that and you say,
hey,
it's,
you know,
I should have done this better.
Right?
So it was like obvious,
like that's,
that has never been your job,
not the,
you know,
since whatever,
whatever that may be.
Right.
So obviously I'm like,
I know you're doing your third grid,
extreme ownership,
you know,
just so we can get the problem.
I get it.
But to me,
what I felt was not what you're doing,
but what you're not doing.
You're not telling me,
hey,
what's up with this?
You know,
hey,
why did you make that you're not,
you're not attacking me.
So I have to be defensive.
You know,
you're not doing that.
I'm just not defensive.
I see what you're doing,
the whole thing.
But who cares?
I don't have to defend myself,
so whatever.
I'll be like,
okay,
all right,
and you would you want to do is get it done.
Whatever the thing is,
we all want to get it done.
That's the thing.
We all want a,
even like with your wife,
that's a,
that's a huge one.
So you guys always talking in context of business and you know the boss and the
subordinates,
whatever.
Same exact thing with your wife.
Same thing.
Even though it feels like counter intuitive,
you know you're,
you're you,
you had all this stuff to do that you're doing for her,
by the way.
And you didn't take out the trash.
I don't know.
I'm not saying that happened to me and not saying it didn't happen to me,
but he didn't take out the trash.
Meanwhile,
you did literally from the moment you will look up to that moment,
you gotta,
you know,
accused whatever you did stuff for her,
right?
You could have done that.
Hypothetically,
you heard her saying,
hey,
you know,
you,
you didn't take out the trash.
All those feelings in your mind and your heart is to,
it's not to be like,
you're right,
I should have done that.
It's not just say that as I say,
the opposite.
Yeah.
That's like
the point where it's overwhelming.
Overwhelming.
Like I will not,
and cannot bring myself to say,
you're right,
you're right about that.
But if you can manage to do that,
you'd be baffled how easy,
how good it works.
It works.
Yeah.
But yeah,
it's,
it's what you're not doing.
I think like if you know,
like,
I see what you're doing,
I see what you're doing.
They're using your little chocolate tricks,
all this stuff.
That's not the influential part.
Influential part is what you're not doing.
You know,
it's so funny now because everyone I deal with now,
every single person that I deal with on any level,
on any,
on any depth at all,
they all know all of my little tricks,
as you call them.
They all know every,
every person I'm involved with knows mall.
Yeah.
And it's like,
yeah,
but yeah.
Cool.
I'll go even one further with this guy.
He'll go hill.
It's almost like he'll double do it to the point where it's a joke insulting you
and you think it's funny yet you're still not vet.
So he'll be like,
I dunno,
whatever.
Let's say I didn't press record on the thing.
Forgot.
We'll just say never done that before.
May or may not have ever done that before.
But he'll be like,
hey,
you're right.
You know I should,
I should have double and triple check that thing.
You know,
I mean it's wherever they are,
but I still totally couldn't,
you know,
so obvious he's throwing it in your face.
You know that it's not his fault.
But he's like going through the motions.
Almost like,
like con kind of condescending,
you know.
But it's so funny that,
cause that's the rule.
So it's like he's,
he,
he's blaming you but he's not really officially blaming you and it says Joe,
but it still works.
That's the thing,
cause it's all just one in meanwhile,
the whole recording is trashed by the way,
cause it didn't even happen.
But yeah,
you're not defensive because it's just,
you know,
it's like,
well I don't,
I don't say this.
The reason to why it works,
quote unquote,
the reason it works is that the reason it works with the people that I deal with
in my life,
for my family took my business partners across the board.
The reason that it works is because I'm not doing it.
For me,
that's the big difference.
So if you're out there and you're thinking,
oh cool,
I'm going to learn these tactics so I can,
I can get further in my life and I can get things out of the world.
It's like,
no,
it's not going to work out well for you.
Yeah.
On the surface.
Cause I'm going to tell you what,
you got to take that one step further because guess what,
if this is the,
this is the amazing thing.
If what you're doing is you're focused on taking care of the team,
taking care of your people,
doing the right thing for the right reasons,
and you're,
and you think to yourself,
so if you're listening this right now going,
well,
I really want to,
I really want to get ahead.
Yeah.
And Jocko just said,
I'm
not going to get ahead.
If I,
if I put myself to get ahead,
then it's not going to work.
So this isn't for me.
Here's the,
here's the dichotomy in this thing and it's a huge dichotomy.
If you're there and you're in a leadership position or you're just in a
position,
you were in a relationship whenever and you're doing things for the team,
you're trying to take care of the others,
you're putting other people above you.
In the end,
you're going to win and you're going to win way bigger than you could if you
were crawling and scratching and ripping things and bringing them back to
yourself.
The end,
that person that thinks,
that thinks that they're doing the right thing or thinks that they're doing
something good for themselves,
but what they're really doing is taking things from other people.
That person,
they might get a couple of tactical victories along the way,
but in the end,
the person that puts everyone else first is going to win.
They are going to win.
So it's,
it's kind of hypocritical because it's like in one hand it's like,
no,
I don't care about myself.
I'm not trying to improve.
I'm not trying to try and improve my station in life.
But by doing that,
you will improve your station in life and you will improve your station in life
beyond anything that you could've done if your goal was to improve your station
in life.
It's true.
Okay.
That's good stuff right there.
Yes.
Here it is.
Take note of that one.
Yeah.
Any other major topics that you want to bring up tonight?
It works especially with your wife.
Not also,
but especially with your wife.
Yeah.
And so it should just be habit that anytime she says you didn't do this,
it actually she's right.
You didn't.
Yeah.
And just be like,
you're right.
I didn't,
yeah,
I have learned that lesson.
Yeah.
A few times.
And,
and again,
this is going to sound obvious,
but it's one of the things you've got to kind of consciously remember,
especially if you're with your wife,
with someone you're with every day or really,
really often the part,
yeah.
You take it,
you take ownership,
you know,
you take responsibility,
but then you actually do have to actually solve the problem.
Yep.
Because if you're like,
hey,
you ride in and take out that trash,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
it won't happen again.
And then tomorrow,
same thing come out.
Same thing next week,
same thing,
same thing.
Yeah.
Then you just sort of become the husband that doesn't take out the trash and it
just says,
yeah,
it's my fault kind of thing.
And you,
you the become the end.
That's my bad,
my bad,
my bad.
Sorry about that.
And then that's all you do is say that it's on me.
Yeah.
And yeah,
so don't,
I mean obviously don't be letting the volt one of you trick,
take out the trash once in a while kind of thing.
You know,
obviously you don't say that.
Um,
but you actually do have to take out the trash.
You do problems get solved.
See,
I learned that from Jocko.
All right,
that's a good one.
And Dave,
obviously,
thank you for coming on again,
thanks for your service in the Marine Corps and for everything you've done for
America.
It's always an honor to have known you to have worked with you.
And it's an honor to be working with you right now.
And I actually want to close out this conversation with another letter.
Okay.
And it's also written by that same,
that same young,
articulate,
even poetic Marine Corps machine gunner,
Saul Seagal,
who wrote the letter that opened this podcast.
And this one is written to the cousin of one of his comrades,
one of his comrades named James Trowbridge.
And the cousin did not know what happened to her cousin,
Corporal Trowbridge,
who had gone missing in World War One and she didn't know what happened to him.
And so this is another letter written after the end of the war.
It's dated February 18th,
okay.
And it reads my dear Miss Trowbridge,
my old sergeant major Clifford has written me and has enclosed a copy of your
letter to him in which you request information concerning your cousin,
Corporal James H Trowbridge.
It is it indeed unfortunate that his family should be left so uncertain
concerning his sad end.
I know that it has been the cause of great concern with you.
I am sorry to that.
I had not known of this before for I was the last of his friends to see him
alive.
No,
Sergeant Clifford wrote me January 16th I have been out adventuring in the oil
fields of northern Texas and I have only lately ventured back into civilization.
Yeah,
your letter was forwarded to me from my home in a while and I received it
tonight and I'm taking this first occasion to answer it.
I hope it will clear up Jim's case.
If there's anything I can do in the future and he service,
I can perform.
Any advice I can offer to Jim's folks,
I will be at their service at all times.
Yeah.
We who have survived this,
how on earth count it the least we can do to console the sorrowing mothers and
families of our dead comrades in arms.
Okay.
I still remember when I first met Jim,
it was in Bella Woods.
Yeah.
On the 13th of June we were making ready for the attack when replacements
arrived to fill up our broken ranks.
Jim was assigned to my gun crew and the way he went over the top,
like the brave soldier,
he always was,
and his subsequent actions made me his proud friend and comrade
to the day he went west.
I still remember one night on guard with Jim in the little hole alongside the
night,
held an eerie stillness a night fit for such a hell hole.
I was definitely tired and though there was no wire,
only an empty space between the Germans and us.
I slept 10 gym like the good pal.
He was kept watch until the officer of the watch came by when he awakened me
that I might not be shot for sleeping at my post.
It was for deeds like that that every man in the company idolized him
and I can assure you that Jim Trowbridge name and memory will forever be held in
reverence by the survivors of the 23rd company.
Okay,
so many men were wounded and left us then came back during the battles that
followed bellow woods to the last phase of the are gone drive that I must
confess ignorance as to whether Jim was or not.
You see,
Jim was assigned to a crew of his own and a machine gun of his own and on the
battle line,
the number one and number 10 gun maybe in the same company.
Yet they are a world apart.
Each carries on and knows that the other is carrying on and sold.
The battle is won.
Yet I dimly remembered that Jim was either gassed or wounded in the champagne
drive in which the second division captured Montblanc Ridge.
It began on October 2nd,
1918 Jim came back to us before the last phase of the are gone drive,
which began on November 1st,
1918 through the mud and rain and fog.
We pushed forward over the top,
that Glorious Day,
the second division leading the whole army.
We captured every piece of Bush field artillery,
white hot.
They were,
and we sent the German scurrying back and broke.
They're invincible line to bits.
My company suffered terribly in dead and wounded.
Yeah.
We carried on hungry and tired and facing the everlasting hail of bullets and
shells.
Okay.
We pushed forward for six days battling steadily.
The 6th of November rose.
I remember passing gym by the road side and he gave me a cheery hale.
Then he followed up the rear.
We went forward and the Boesch began shelling us.
As the last of the column came up,
I heard from them that Jim's crew had rested once again by the road side.
None of us were strong.
We had not eaten in days.
A great shell had exploded and it killed and wounded all of Jim's crew.
Jim had had a foot torn off by a flying fragment.
There was death and destruction all about.
I volunteered to help carry a wounded man back to the first aid station.
There
was Jim lying on the blanketed floor.
Yeah.
I knelt down to speak to him.
Okay.
I mark that his face was already drawn with pain and that he was gray from long
exposure and loss of blood.
He said,
Saul,
old bow,
I'm dying.
Good luck to you.
Old Man.
I tried to cheer him up,
but to no avail
on the battlefield one knows when death approaches.
Yeah,
that is all I know.
For a few hours later I was knocked out myself
yet I doubt not the gym went west to home and to mother soon after
whether Jim died and was buried in the village a few miles south of Sudan in the
Ardennes Department or whether he survived until he reached the hospital.
I do not know.
You can find out by writing the graves registration bureau at Washington
that he is gone.
I am reasonably sure
I would advise his family to harbor.
No unfounded hopes and his safety.
It is with deep regret that I ask yours.
And Jim's mother's pardon for my heart.
Listen,
brutal description of this story.
My experiences on the battlefield of caused me to use other than Tinder words
that might sue the brokenhearted mother.
Believe me,
nevertheless,
that I grieve with her for her son and my comrade.
Okay.
And believe me too,
that I stand ready to do all in my power to assist her in any possible way.
It is hard,
I know yet at such a cost has liberty and democracy survived
except my dear Ms Trowbridge,
the assurance of my profound
respect,
most sincerely
Saul Segal.
So
liberty and democracy survived
but
at such a cost and so many bore that cost.
The fighting that salsa girl writes about
was part of the Muse Argon offensive.
Here's part of the hundred days offensive
that brought the war to an end
and we'll bring you into the war to the end.
It cost the lives of 26,277 Americans.
Yeah.
And Corporal James Trowbridge was one of those Americans.
He died around the 6th of November,
1918 okay.
And as we know
the armistice was signed,
then the war ended
just five days later
on November 11th,
war is hell.
Then the cost of liberty in the cost of democracy is immense.
And I started this podcast,
we were talking about that quote.
Okay.
The quote that says when you know the way broadly
you see it and everything.
Well in that vein,
I think that if you know the cost broadly,
if you know the cost of freedom,
then you see it.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
And everything
in everything
that we have been given,
especially our most precious gift.
Yeah.
And that is
freedom.
And
I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
And I think at this point,
Echo,
if you want to,
uh,
maybe give us an opportunity to decompress or,
sure.
Maybe we could help you talk about
how we can take advantage of the freedom that we have.
Yes sir.
Cool.
We'll do both.
Okay.
Look that
support yourself too,
by the way,
Dave work.
So first we'll talk about origin.
I know little bit of a rough transition cause yeah,
cause that's a,
that's a letter right there.
Yeah.
Again,
21 now he's,
so now he's 22,000 says 1920 he's 22 years old,
Dave.
Yeah.
Unreal.
You've tried to figure out what happened to him,
like where,
where you went.
Did he take over like a big company?
He must've done something awesome.
Saul Segal,
Segal,
Segal.
Yeah.
It's s e,
g.
E.
L.
He shoot him.
Become a writer.
They should have absolutely become a writer.
Yeah.
You,
you know,
you read these letters and again you say this whole time,
but you kind of can't help but remember,
especially this can letters that like this actual person.
It's not just some cool letter,
you know,
kind of thing.
It's like does the actual person writing this letter to an actual person?
Just like all about an actual person about James Trowbridge.
Yeah.
Crazy.
All right,
well I guess we can talk about origin
made in America.
I guess there's that.
There's that.
So yeah.
So again,
origin.
Yes.
So they have American made products,
good products too,
as in the best.
Yeah.
I think they're the best buy.
Here's the thing.
You know when people are like,
yeah,
they got the best thing.
It's like it's a matter of opinion.
So I can't tell you they're the best,
but I can't tell you,
I think.
Can you not say it's the best key?
Yeah.
Oh it's the best for factually.
That's a factual leafing.
Yep.
So gies so yeah,
if,
okay.
On the path we're on the path,
the Burke,
you're on the path on the GC path you did as part of that path.
Optional for sure.
Optional,
but it is part of the path cause not,
not part of the path.
You see I'm saying so when you questioning whether it's optional for the moment,
no,
because you've heard of people who don't necessarily do Jujitsu,
but they're on the pedal on the path.
If you,
yeah,
you should try and train Jujitsu though.
Here's my recommendation.
It's like strongly recommend Dave recommendation,
Yay or Nay Jiu Jitsu.
It's not a recommendation.
You need to do it.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's just,
it's something unlike anything else I've ever done and it's something you need
to do and it's,
there's a million different reasons to do it and it's,
look,
echo,
it's not an option if you're on the path,
you're training when you heard it here.
So by the way,
representing the origin tee shirt.
If someone's wondering about the g designy boy you Willie.
So boom,
there you go.
So when you started you just two or if you're on that you need the bathroom
already.
You need a new geek or didn't get best one made in America.
100% cottons made it in America.
They make them with the other stuff obviously cause it's,
you know,
they got rash guards in other Jujitsu stuff on there as well.
Origin main.com joggers.
Okay.
How you feel about joggers overall?
I mean we come a long way.
Let's face it,
if you,
are you indicating that I have made some movement towards,
I'm going to be sporting a pair of joggers if that's what you're thinking.
It's not you.
There's been no movement,
no movement.
Still one that pre phase one,
phase one.
Yup.
They're not happening for me.
Would you say anti joggers?
Possibly,
cause I've been wearing a lot about to anti.
I don't look at people and say,
aw man,
I can't believe that guy is wearing joggers.
I don't care about it that much,
but it's still like it's a zero.
It's not a negative.
It's just the idea of jobs.
Well,
I have something that I don't get.
Yeah,
I dig it,
man.
There's lots of things that you know you might not get.
Nonetheless.
I am not in that boat.
I think just a lot of things.
I'm just saying there are things that you kind of don't get overall all depends
on what you mean by anyway.
Joggers tee shirts,
obviously Dave Burke representing big time hardcore,
if you will.
Big Time.
Huge time actually.
Yeah.
Look at that shirt.
It's dope.
Anyway,
there are a legit shirt sweats as well.
You know sweat suits most comfortable in the world.
That's factually,
that's like not even a matter of opinion.
Sure.
Sounds like it's not though.
Also supplements.
Okay.
Dig Burke.
You're on the dislocate.
Their supplements,
right?
Jocko.
Super Krill oil free joints.
Omega threes,
all that antioxidants in there,
all kinds of stuff.
Good for your joints.
Legitimately not this,
you know,
one a day commercial thing.
This is for real good for your joints.
That's that joint warfare.
Good for your joints in a different way,
but very good for the joints.
Discipline,
good for your brain,
good for your muscles
called discipline.
Preworkout pre cognitive,
not pre-cognitive,
but pre mission,
we'll call it cognitive enhancing neutrals.
Okay,
well you know who's down with the discipline day,
Burke,
I am down with the discipline.
What,
when do you take it?
I take it usually twice a day,
so get up,
work out.
I'm tracking for a while and about 10 10 30 and I,
that's about the time I sit down and I'd have to,
I got to grind at my computer and I really don't want to,
but I need to and I got to put my brain in the,
I will take discipline and I'll crank for a while.
And then the other time I do it as typically like post bedtime.
The kids and I would have really liked to do is just call it a day.
Oh.
But I,
but I can't get some.
Yeah,
I got to that and that's,
that's what I'll take it.
What about pre Jujitsu?
I every time I go train on the,
on the,
on the drive I thought he'd be like,
well no,
not really because know he's like every time I go train I was mixing one up at
the house today and he's like,
oh what are we going to roll?
And I was like,
yeah.
And he goes,
can I get something of that?
You had to go to religious schools there.
These are heaping skewers or I think it might end up being four.
And I don't know if you noticed this,
but I had a pretty small water bottle.
I'm mixing up these suits.
Super
charged to concentrate,
concentrate.
I have eaten it before.
It doesn't taste good bra.
Right?
You don't want to have done it if I had to.
But anyway,
so that's discipline.
I did.
And then you,
you take milk again.
This is good that you're here.
Cause I tell everyone that tastes good,
that to me,
but I'm only one person.
You like it to mince your flavor too,
right?
He,
okay.
So here's the thing,
I got to explain that because you're here,
Dave Burke,
you're here,
you're on the discipline train.
I dig it.
I'm on the mark train.
Okay,
so
here's the thing.
I never wasn't,
and even like,
you know,
even macro college,
a number of episodes ago,
I would say more than once,
by the way,
that I'm like protein powder that's with the kids take to make them think
they're getting big,
whatever.
Right?
That's kind of how I felt about it and I,
you know,
okay,
we'll say that,
but okay,
so Pete sent me the vanilla who's in a blank container.
It's not done or,
yeah,
yeah.
So it's kind of like,
So I'm like,
cool.
I put it in.
I was like,
Dang,
this is pretty good
interest is the vanilla,
by the way.
A good flavor.
Right?
I think even like one of the definitions of vanilla is like,
it's just cool.
It's fine.
We're not excited about vanilla,
but it's good.
But you were on a little bit.
I got a little bit excited.
So I'm like,
hmm.
But it could be my bias.
You know,
it's Pete,
you know,
thanks p and he get the big box here all excited.
It could be,
you know,
you can be biased results.
So I'm like,
all right,
you know what the test is?
Here's the test.
I have a one year or two year,
he's almost too,
oh yeah.
So I'm like,
all right,
let me back up.
So I give it to him.
I don't recommend giving them a bunch.
I don't know if all the protein,
22 grams of protein by the way,
two grams of sugar,
no one gram of to total carbs,
two grams of fat,
by the way,
which I mean feel how you want to feel about fat.
Like it's good or whatever.
But Bruh,
this is a for real protein deal.
Like you want an extra protein,
they're not going to give you a bunch of this stuff.
He didn't sign up for anyway,
side note.
So I'm like,
okay,
my sons,
do you have a real problem with things that you don't sign up for her?
I noticed that about him.
One of your things,
one of them sign up for something and it comes anyways.
You don't like that unless it's a box of good stuff from Pete,
then you didn't sign up for it.
If I do like it
there is that.
Yes.
So boom,
I give it to them.
Mix it up.
Nope.
By the way,
just to beat in the spirit of accuracy.
Boom.
Hit it.
Yeah,
you liked it.
So I'm like,
oh,
okay.
But it could be one of those things.
Was that meant or was that vanilla?
No,
Nate up Manila.
Yeah.
So I'm like,
all right,
well it could it be anomaly in how you give like someone that maybe thought it
was milk,
I don't know.
Little taste it,
you know?
So he's like more,
more,
more all I'm trying to get out of my phone so I can think of video to send to
Pete.
And he's like,
boy,
he's kind of tripping.
So I'm like all right until I finally get the video going and I give it to him.
Yeah he wants it.
Wants the milk.
Two year old drinking malt.
Not say to give it to your two year old's.
I'm saying as a taste test that works cause that's vanilla by the way.
So anyway,
tell us,
confirmed,
confirmed and that's vanilla.
So I like the mint chocolate.
We better hundred percent and peanut butter chocolate is now
live@originmain.com.
Is that official official?
That's official.
Yes.
All right.
That is official.
So all my Twitter competition of WHO's going to get the first peanut butter
chocolate?
It's on.
It's good to,
it's good because I've had it cause we,
we test it and we went through like three.
It didn't have,
the cool thing is it didn't take that many iterations to get it.
It was like a little bit more chocolate,
a little bit more peanut butter.
All right.
I think it was three iterations and we were good.
I will say this,
send it to you please.
I put like a half a tablespoon of peanut butter in the Mitchell by the way as a
test and boom.
I like that too.
So we go.
So yeah,
we were waiting for that anyway.
Yeah.
And don't forget the Krill are in the joint warfare.
These are daily things.
We need this.
Yeah,
take it from me.
We need this little run out.
Also good way to support and represent cause representing is a method of support
in my opinion.
Jack was the store.
It's called Jocko store.
You can get Jocko gear,
rash guards,
Jocko gear.
I guess like more geared towards the game,
get after it,
all that stuff.
Anyway.
Yeah.
Rash guards,
tee shirts,
discipline equals freedom,
all these things.
A lot of stuff.
Concepts conceptually representing by way of apparel.
You don't like the word apparel,
clothing,
apparel,
those things.
Fashion.
No.
Oh,
okay.
Got You.
So anyway,
accessories if you will.
Some some hats on.
They're some good stuff.
The women's stuff on there.
If you want to represent,
go to Jocko store.com that's where you get the stuff.
Also you want to subscribe to the podcast.
If you haven't already,
seems obvious.
I know.
And that's on stitcher,
iTunes,
Google play,
you know all these places where they play podcasts.
Good way to support and leave a review
and don't forget about this podcast.
Also,
there's a warrior kid podcast is so subscribe to the war warrior kid podcast.
Dave Burke was the first guest on the Warrior Kid podcast number 16 which is out
at this time if you want to hear him answer questions from children about being
a Marine Corps fighter pilot.
And there's also some stories from Uncle Jake in the most recent three podcasts,
1415 and 16 there's some stories from uncle Jake talking about how uncle Jake
kind of established his principles in life.
So those are pretty cool.
And and in addition to the warrior kid podcast being available through the
various podcast channels,
it is also available on youtube on a separate channel from the Jocko podcast
youtube channel,
which has this podcast on it,
which is pretty cool.
But it also has the custom artistic artistic
idioms
videos.
I was looking at enhancing and wicked cool videos from Echo Charles with about
whatever about whatever.
Yet and well,
hey,
we did this event.
We just actually David,
I just did an event and they played the warpath video,
the good one and it was on it.
No,
this is legit.
It was on a giant screen with us six sound system and it was pretty cool.
Yeah.
Cool to actually,
that legitimately doesn't make me feel good.
And the big,
big crystal clear HD TV,
something with the whole deal and it is a four K TV.
It was mass probably and I was like four feet from it cause we were about to
walk on stage,
so I was real close to it.
Yeah,
I know I've got the full,
yeah.
Yeah.
You are.
You do your Ninja pose.
Ninja Jed.
I don't think Ninjas do.
Nonetheless.
The youtube thing,
I'll think about this too sometimes,
like when one podcasts come out,
not necessarily art,
but you know,
other podcasts or whatever.
Sometimes they'll put it on youtube,
but they'll just have an image on there.
Oh yeah.
Just for another source of audio,
which is good.
More than that.
Yeah.
You've got the added dimension where we do it is a video pot.
So if you want to see what Dave Burke looks like,
if you don't know,
I'm saying we to see what it looks like.
If for some reason,
I don't know,
boom,
you can do what it looks like.
I liked that picture.
Somebody posted of what they thought you looked like.
You know what?
I'm going to ask that question on the soul.
Sure.
I'm gonna say,
what did you think Echo Charles looked like?
And we'll just see how that goes.
Yeah,
that seems like that.
What did you think echo looked like?
I think it looks exactly the way he does.
I was not in the least bit surprised.
Oh,
you,
you okay,
sure.
Good deal.
Dave Berg.
Yeah.
Knows it,
man.
You heard it here.
Actually wait,
did you,
but you didn't hear me first.
You met me first,
right?
That was early enough.
Or did you hear,
I guess my coins.
I,
I heard you long before I met you.
Oh yeah.
You can tell.
Well,
boom,
there it is.
Youtube subscribe if you want.
If you'll uh,
you know,
in a good way to support really good.
Also to switch up your workout.
Get some kettlebells,
get some battle ropes,
get a jump rope if you don't have one.
Get some.
I just got some battle ropes they didn't come in yet is I think it's good for my
workout.
I got planned.
Oh and I've got some rings.
Boom.
You'd think I already had rings.
How much you talk about?
No,
you did not have rain.
Not Have Rings.
I had pull up bar.
I have,
you know that kind of,
but I don't have rings.
I have rings now.
I didn't come in yet.
They're on the way.
But anyway,
you go to [inaudible] dot com slash jock good stuff on,
oh sorry.
Slash Jocko.
Not Job on it.
Dot Com slash Jocko.
They got some good workout stuff on there.
A lot of good info too.
That's where I went when us,
when I was starting the kettle bar.
Bell routine.
Got got the info from there.
Good stuff.
Get some socks too.
By the way.
Psychological warfare album,
you can get it album with tracks,
blah,
blah.
Nobody has to deal with some people.
They didn't know what to iTunes.
Go to Google play,
go to MP3.
You can get an album with me talking about why you shouldn't be weak for the
various reasons.
That's it.
That's all we're saying about it.
Other than to say we are working on the new psychological warfare album.
However,
each time I say that I should,
I should caveat that by saying I haven't had a lot of other things to do,
so I am,
the work I have done so far on the new psychological warfare album is to begin
to consider topics for the next album.
I have a small list.
It will be rolled out.
What do you think?
We'll just roll that out,
but when people want smoking,
he said,
really?
Someone's out there that wants to quit smoking.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right,
so we're on that.
We'll put it out there.
The new psychological warfare,
we do have a working title,
which seems to be sticking pretty well.
All your excuses are lies.
Psychological warfare to,
that's the one.
Hopefully it'll be better than jobs too,
but not terminated,
but not terminator to Terminator two was just as iconic as terminator one roping
good.
Then Jocko white tea.
You can get it on Amazon.
You can get the dry tea bags and mix it yourself or you can get it in a can and
if you get it,
no big deal.
You can deadlift 8,000 pounds.
Weigh the warrior kid books.
Dave,
you've read them.
I've read them multiple times.
They are on or reread in the house.
You got three kids ages nine,
seven,
four and their feedback is feedback is solid.
The girls loved the books.
Interesting.
People ask me,
what about girls?
Are you gonna write a book for girls?
I did write
a book for girls.
It's called way of the warrior kept.
Yep.
Agree.
I,
I've seen my lessons are universal.
Kids love it.
My girls love it.
Girls started training Jujitsu because of the book.
That's awesome.
Yep.
Did they study?
They study.
Do they eat a little bit more healthy?
Look,
they're on the path.
No joke here and there on the math.
It's a legit,
that's awesome.
And I actually talked to your kids occasionally and I see that they are in fact
on the path.
What about the field manual?
They have not read the field field manual.
I have read the field manual feedback.
Feedback.
Feedback is also legit.
It is a prescription if you need some help on getting and staying on the path.
Read the field manual.
Have you ever read three pages of the,
of the field manual?
Just because three pages.
Have you just been like,
you know,
you're sitting there and it's on your desk and you're like,
you know what,
I'm going to check.
I'm going to read this real quick.
Yeah,
so the thing about the book is the cover of the book that cover says open this
book.
It's cover is awesome at that.
Hardcover is as legit man.
They asked me like,
all right,
when would you like to call at the soft cover?
I'm like,
ah,
never know.
That is not a softcover book.
No,
it is not.
No.
There's an iconic picture.
They say,
Echo says there's an iconic picture.
I think he's got a clinic Togare for that.
Took the picture.
Had An incredible day.
That day sense?
No for art.
Okay.
I didn't say that for the soft cover.
None.
Oh yeah.
Say I don't care what the picture looks like.
There's no soft corners.
Well it is actually when I said it's an iconic picture means less of the notion
or the idea that I took a great picture or nothing like this.
I'm saying that picture that we took in my hallway,
one random night,
cheap camera became a picture.
That's kind of representative iconic,
if you will.
Okay,
so he's claiming it of,
you know,
your whole,
he's trying to downplay it.
It could be called iconic picture that I took random night.
No big deal.
Well you look at where the word kid,
the picture on the back of that one I took down too.
But is that iconic?
Not,
maybe not.
It didn't push me in that direction necessarily,
but the one on the cover of discipline equals freedom field manual is the
fabulous.
You're wanted a picture of me when I looked more approachable.
The one in the back and there's something about the warrior kid books that you
didn't mention though.
You said you wrote a kids book.
That's for boys and girls.
Yeah,
that's actually a book for adults too.
Now I said not just not just for the adults.
There are lessons for the adults,
but that book is a great parenting co parenting tool that I now get to go.
Is that what mark would do?
What would uncle Jake say here and I actually get to parent less now because I
just referenced the book.
That's,
that's no joke,
man.
That word ultimate flank.
It is.
It
really is,
is the absolute plank because here's the problem.
Kids do not listen to their parents.
Kids listen to a certain percentage of what their parents say and there's a
certain portion of them that is programmed to rebel against you as a parent.
They're programmed that way and the more you fight it,
the worse it's gonna get you come in from the flank.
Boom.
There you go.
Yeah,
that's true.
Good point.
What about Dave?
This is your big night.
What about extreme ownership feedback?
Feedback?
I've read that book several times.
I've listened to it.
I referenced the book constantly because of the work that we do and I get a lot
of feedback on that book.
That is the book that when you talk about,
when you see it broadly,
that quote from Musashi,
you start to see it everywhere.
That's what that book is because once you tip on that and once that gets
embedded in your DNA,
once you start doing that,
you will see that every where and that is what's unique about that book.
Yes,
the best feedback I've ever gotten on that book from the people that we're
working on until they say it just makes sense.
We have a follow on to that book coming out.
It's called the dichotomy of leadership.
It's about all those opposing forces you face as a leader and I talked about the
ultimate dichotomy tonight and so that book comes out September 25th
also,
if you need live training,
you need a little bit more than the book and you a little bit more than the
podcasts you can bring us inside your organization.
We have a company called national in front.
That's what Dave was talking about tonight.
I was talking about tonight.
All the companies that we work with,
that's what we're talking about.
We solve problems through leadership.
Boom,
me,
Leif,
JP,
Dave Burke,
Flynn Cochran,
and now we also have Mike Cirelli in the house.
All right.
What about the monster?
Unless her six coming up San Francisco,
this will be my fifth muster.
Oh yeah.
Sorry you missed the first one.
I did not make the first muster,
but um,
this muster like every other muster is a going to be awesome and be,
it's going to sell out.
Yeah.
Actually it's going to sell.
It's almost there.
Yeah.
I talked to Jimmy just the other day about it.
We are tracking way ahead of where we expected it is going to sell out soon.
You gotta get on it?
No,
because of the muster.
We actually designed something else because we wanted to do something.
First of all,
the monsters got a pretty high price point.
It's pretty expensive and it focuses on real broad leadership across the board.
But we have had come to all the ministers,
law enforcement,
military border patrol,
firefighters,
paramedics,
other first responders.
We wanted to do something a little bit
a little bit focused on what they do for a living.
So we have something called the roll call.
It is September 21st in Dallas,
Texas.
It's one day leadership seminar for everyone out there in uniform.
So if you're a police officer,
if you're a firefighter,
and we've worked with police officers and firefighters and we've worked with
border patrol and and we've worked with military units and we still do all of
that.
But if you want to come and get a one day immersion into the combat leadership
principles that we talk about in the book,
extreme ownership that we talk about on this podcast,
come to the roll call,
sub tone September 21st in Dallas,
Texas.
And for both the muster and the roll call,
you can register for those@extremeownership.com.
On top of all of that.
We have something now called echelon front,
Overwatch,
e f overwatch.com and Dave,
you've been involved pretty heavily in US standing that up.
We are,
we in our business working with companies,
we are always running into companies that need,
what do they need?
They need good leaders,
they need good people,
and because of our connections to the military,
all of us having spent extended periods of time in the military and special
operation as combat pilots,
we have connections there and this is a place where we have an opportunity to
bring those two things together.
People that want great leaders and people that are great leaders that need jobs.
So we're bringing those together.
Whether you're somebody who wants to employ people or whether you're looking to
be employed as a spec ops individual or a combat pilot,
then go to f overwatch.com put your information in there and we will proceed
down the line of getting you the best people you can.
And I miss anything on the F Overwatch.
It's is like you said,
and the best thing for the transitioning folks,
if you're looking for a new mission to find your next mission and after you
transitioned out of the service,
this is the place to do it.
Come and get some.
And if you want to kind of keep carrying on this conversation with us virtually,
that is until we see you in the either at the muster or at the roll call or at
the immersion camp up in Maine,
then you can find us all on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on Dash f phase at ball you ball Dave,
is that David R.
Burke B.
E.
R
he
cause that's the thing.
I mean the,
you always forget your own thing.
You're like Dave our Burke.
Yeah.
David are Burke,
correct.
D where you are and you're there.
You're there on Twitter and on Instagram and on Facebook.
You Echo is of course Echo Charles and I am at Jockowillink Echo.
Anything else?
Nope.
Good to see you again.
Dave Burke actually you talk about him always texting you budgets and stuff.
He calls me to thinking.
Yeah,
that's great.
that's how it is,
man.
One of those things,
we see his name on your phone.
You kind of get happy.
Yeah,
just for you know,
you get happen.
You like man was arm lock,
question,
escape at the milds question.
Bit stuff.
Good deal Dave.
Great to see.
[inaudible] date of birth,
any closing comments?
Do it.
Thanks for having me back man.
I could do this all day.
I appreciate the chance to talk again and being a part of this,
a big deal for me.
Thank you chairman.
Awesome to have you on.
And again,
thanks for everything that you've done for me and done for our freedom as a
nation and I'm sure we will do this many times again in the future.
So yeah,
this is just the beginning,
my brother and everyone else in the military that is out there right now
protecting our freedom.
Thank you.
And to the first responders,
police,
law enforcement,
border patrol,
firefighters,
paramedics.
Thanks for keeping us and our families safe and to everyone else that is
listening.
Thank you.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you for supporting and thanks for remembering that the heroes that gave
their lives so that liberty and democracy
can survive
and let the names of the fallen for ever,
for ever be as on perishable as those glorious ideals for which they made the
ultimate sacrifice.
Kinda till next time,
this is Dave,
an echo and Jocko
out.